other than hearing from uh
four
four agencies possibly five
um
we're probably
after we hear
from the department of justice
we're gonna talk very quickly about this
two two uh bills that
came back with senate messages that we
have to determine if we want to concur
or not so we'll just have a brief
discussion on those two
and i'll talk about some of the other
ones that we were second on
and i've already talked to the chairs of
those
uh committees because they're the prime
the the principal uh committees
uh i'll i'll cover that real quickly as
well so uh with that we're going to
start with department of revenue
and uh
and i first want to thank chris for
pulling this all together
and just everybody knows at the end of
all this we are not we are not going to
be voting revenues
we are not we want to we just want to
understand
uh uh especially for department of
revenue the big revenues
um that you know the the numbers are
very large that we have we've
know we made it through march and april
and waiting for the shoe to drop and the
shoe didn't drop it actually dropped in
the other way
so we're
we just wanted to have department of
revenue come and give us any insights
maybe you have a printing press or
something we don't know that
so very good so uh
chris you wanna just
start with the department of revenue
just have them come up come on up
and i wanna
uh oh okay
also um would you
uh lindsay introduce um
robert boos he's the first time that
he's been here so can you just introduce
him a little bit about what he's going
to be doing thank you
good morning lindsay steph commissioner
from the department of revenue with me
today i have kean wong who i believe
many of you have met before is our tax
policy council and robert boos who is
our new financial analyst so we're happy
to welcome robert to the team you have
probably seen his name show up in your
email with the daily revenue reports
so feel free to reach out to any of us
at any time including robert with any
questions about our daily reports
or revenues in general
so thank you mr chair for having
us today
everyone should have a copy hopefully of
a presentation that says department of
revenue administration at the top
dated today may 10th
should look like this
okay
it's not as pretty
[Laughter]
it's the second second thing in the
packet
we can um either chris or i can
we have them
we have the color copies okay so your
it should be in color that's right
so thanks for having us today uh the dra
developed revised fiscal year 22 and 23
revenue estimates for
the major dra the major taxes that dra
collects the business taxes meals and
rentals tax tobacco interest and
dividends communication services tax
real estate transfer tax and utility
property tax
what we did is we adjusted fiscal year
22 plan based on currently available
data through april as well as estimating
revenues for may and june that formed
our 22 estimates and then we applied a
growth rate either positive or negative
to our 22 plan to robot arrive at 23
estimates
so on this first page here you will see
a summary
fiscal year 22 plan
was
um
1.8 billion dollars year-to-date or
excuse me our revised estimates are just
about 2.2 billion
so compared to plan we are estimating to
end the year
at 330
uh 331 and a half million dollars ahead
of planner 17.8 percent year to date
through april um we are
307.1 million or 22.3 percent ahead of
plan
looking at fiscal year 23
original plan was 1.8 billion our
revised estimates are 2.1 billion
which is a 268 million dollar increase
or 14.6 percent
i will say that we expect some
volatility
in our estimates and in economic
performance in general in the near to
long term
elements that are having a direct impact
on the economic outlook
include persisting inflation increasing
interest rates low unemployment rate
volatile fuel prices and supply chain
constraints all of which are changing on
a daily basis so
basically as soon as we print these
estimates they're probably outdated
so my goal today is to help you
understand the factors that we're
considering when we're looking at
revenue estimates over the next few
months the summer and through the fall
and um obviously these are subject to
change and will change as the months go
on
lindsay can i interrupt you sure
so
uh
last month there was negative growth in
the country
uh so it takes three to say it's in it's
a recession but
i'm sure that's weighing the back of
your mind as well i don't i didn't see
recession on this list but
it is and you know chris and i were
chatting before we got started this
morning and i think um we've been
waiting for this impending recession for
years now and every time we think it's
coming it hasn't come yet it hasn't come
yet it hasn't come yet so not to say
it's not coming i think it is it's
really just a question of when and i
think it has to do with these various
factors here
how they continue to persist
does inflation continue to rise is the
federal reserve successful with kind of
tampering legislation
it's all going to depend and it's all
going to be things that we're looking at
um
and i guess we would know by the time we
have to project revenues again next
you know january february correct
correct we will know where we're at
we'll know we'll know better where we're
at
at that point okay thank you sure
and actually that is a good point
one of the reasons why these estimates
are looking so high compared to plan is
i think in many cases we were
anticipating the impacts of koba to
result in a recession and that fiscal
year 22 and 23 we were maybe going to be
in a recession and we're not yet so
that's why these revenue estimates look
so high compared to plan because the
plan you know we were anticipating at
least some amount of an economic
downturn
on page two
this is just a nice visual to show that
actual revenues compared to plan for
fiscal year 22 to date so as i mentioned
we have consistently been above plan um
throughout the year again i think
when the plan estimates were developed
we were anticipating um some at least
some economic downturn as a result of
cobit
and in many cases we just haven't seen
that so you can see we have performed
well the the increases in actual in plan
in september december and april um those
tie to the business tax estimates and
on page three we normally wait for
business taxes to do it at the end but
we're just going to dive right in head
first this time
so
at the top and you'll see this for every
tax that i'm going to go over this
morning you'll see a bar graph here of
fiscal year 20 revenue compared to 21
and 22 and then we've also noted fiscal
22 plan so it's kind of a nice visual
comparison about how revenues have been
performing over the past few years
so factors to consider with business
taxes
fiscal year to date we are
217.2 million or
and a half percent ahead of plan
and we are
198.6 or 24.5 percent ahead of prior
year
the u.s bureau of economic analysis
preliminary report in march showed that
new hampshire had a 7.9 percent increase
in real gdp
in q4 of 2021 as compared to
q3 of 2021 so we are still at least at
the end of 2021 we are experiencing an
increase in growth in our real gdp here
in new hampshire
moving on to page four
the same group estimated a tempered
growth in u.s profits with quarter over
quarter change from q3 2021 of 3.4
percent to q4 20 21 of 0.7 percent so
again we're still growing at the end of
21 but we're starting to see a little
bit of a reduction in that growth
kiplinger forecast is a two and a half
percent growth in gdp and 22 compared to
21 that's down from a 5.7 percent in 21
compared to 20.
and then talking about inflation
forecasting six percent annual inflation
at the end of 22 down from the current
eight and a half percent rate of
inflation so
again
we're growing but that growth is
yes
thank you
lindsay as i was coming in this morning
i was listening to npr
and
uh
they they had someone on from the
economic policy institute which i
frankly haven't heard of
before
uh so i don't know how good
they did say they were leftist
but they uh
they had calculated that of the profits
net profits that came out of
corporations this last year
on
usually 20 of it goes to
shareholders and owners and
this last year it was over 50
and that on
leaving a lot less for reinvestment and
right so that's another point to what
potentially we could be seeing in the
future in terms of our
businesses adequately preparing for the
future in a potential economic downturn
when they are well prepared the impact
tends to be less if they're not as well
prepared we might see a greater impact
those of you who have been on on this
committee for quite a while um you know
generally when you when we experience a
recession here in new hampshire
we
tend to not fall as far as maybe the
national average but our recovery is
longer in duration so we don't fall as
far but we don't recover as fast either
so just something to keep in mind for
when um if and when we do experience
that economic downturn but certainly
what representative almi brings up could
impact how far
um and how fast we fall if businesses
aren't prepared yes
yeah good morning good morning
um
about a year ago we were when we were
doing the estimates or whatever it was
we were concerned about refunds and uh
i think the ppp
loan and the forgiveness of that were
sort of
uncertainties
that stood out there and i can't really
remember what else there were but there
were
concerns that related to
potentially large refunds and i'm
wondering if you've seen any
indication of that
sure so i'll just
flip to my handy dandy book here
um
and so i can give you an update
on where we stand
with
refunds
so for business taxes
for fiscal year 22 year-to-date through
april our refunds were 57.7
million that is up from 40 million last
year so we've seen about a 44
increase we've just also seen such a
significant increase in revenue
that has kind of
been able to offset that those refunds
but yeah we've seen about a 17 18
million dollar increase in in refunds
year to date
certainly at the time when we were
talking about those revenue estimates
and the potential for refunds i think we
were also a little bit uncertain about
what the economy was going to be doing
and we see increased refund requests
when there's either uncertainty in the
economy or there's an economic downturn
because businesses would prefer to have
that cash back in their accounts or in
their pockets for them to use when times
are good we see more businesses request
credit carry forwards rather keep the
money on the account as the economy is
doing well
and so that may also be a little bit of
a difference in terms of the desire for
a cco versus a refund
does that answer your question
representative
real time i i got a question so
we look at the revenue focus that's nets
out right so yeah all that extra money
we saw last month was net of refund
return refunds right thank you
yeah
so it's already melt it's already built
into the numbers and i do um get a
weekly report of pending refunds um and
there is no you know significant backlog
or large pending refunds um that i'm
aware of we're processing them as they
come in so our you know weekly refund
run um is monitored consistently and and
there's nothing there's no big shoe
that's going to drop in that respect all
right thank you uh yes representative
thank you we were really worried about
the ppp refunds
and
the the amount of refunds that we've got
to date is just a little bit more than
what we got two years ago
so
what do you have any idea what's going
on with ppp
well i think to kind of how i ended
representative ames's question um
i think we were anticipating refunds
in that that's what businesses were
going to want given what was going on in
the economy i think the economy is in a
better place
at least at the moment businesses at the
time are competent about their position
and so for any overpayments they just
apply that as a credit and we have seen
an increase in our credit carryovers
so i think it's just the shift between
the two they can either treat the
overpayment as a refund or a credit
carryover
yes
so
it sounds also like they aren't paying
attention to the
the uh
reduction in credit carry forward that
isn't really starting yet but that we've
got in law correct it is in law it has
not go into effect effect yet what
representative elmi's referring to is
hb2 from last year there's a cap on the
amount of busines of credit carry
forwards that businesses can hold on
their account it's capped at 500 percent
and that'll be effective um
for taxable periods ending december 31st
of 22. so we haven't
seen the full impact of that yet
yes
yeah just on that but
then
i was thinking that there would be the
large businesses that would be affected
first that have over 500
in there um that they
would prefer to start taking
part of it back now so that they
wouldn't have to take a huge hit at some
point in the future
agreed um
i think for some of those large
businesses it's um
it's a little bit of how much attention
are they paying to new hampshire
um where they might you know it might be
a large amount of money to us but it
might be a rather small apportionment to
them
um and so it's it's a matter of how does
new hampshire
um fit into their greater scheme of of
taxes and for most large taxpayers were
bill said
okay representative supposedly then
so in terms of projections for
fy23
um isn't the election
to either take a refund now
or leave the overpayment in place in
order to take a credit next year i'm
going to net to the exact same
effect on our revenues it's just a
timing deferral
so in effect
refunds not taken this year might
therefore make it more likely
that there is a reduction of net inflows
next year potentially so we do have some
taxpayers that consistently carry a
credit
credit carryover year to year to year to
year
um
the real the thing that will will
make the strongest impact will be that
cap on the credit carryovers because
they won't have the opportunity to
continue to carry a credit forward
that's greater than 500 it will have to
be a refund at that point for the over
500 percent um
so it's really each individual business
and and various factors and
considerations um
that that they take into account
but yes at the end of the day it is
over whether it's two years or 20 years
and i'm always the one
so you i didn't hear you mention or
maybe i just missed it uh
the course of the pandemic and whether
we have
variants that are more transmissible or
carry into different sections of the
country or things of that nature that
are to do with medical stuff rather than
sort of direct economic things
and but of course we know it has
tremendous economic effect
did do you see that as something that we
need to take into account
so your you didn't miss it i didn't
include it um in the factors to consider
we had listed the covet 19 pandemic as a
factor to consider
for a couple of the taxes as we were
doing revenue estimates
previously
and
for the most part once the stay-at-home
orders were lifted
the pandemic didn't have a negative
effect in some cases it had a positive
effect and you'll see this when we talk
about m r
meals and rentals revenue
is
has maybe been positive again once we
got through the stay-at-home order there
we may be seeing a positive effect just
in terms of there was some pent up
demand maybe people realized how much
they liked going out to eat when they
couldn't go out to eat certainly with
the real estate transfer tax
and what's happened with the housing
economy the pandemic has kind of been a
positive
factor in those taxes
and we haven't been able to
quantify really a direct correlation
between the pandemic and any of the
variants and the timing of the variants
or potential future variants
with kind of especially the impact on
business taxes and so
we had looked into it in the past and
it's
we weren't able to really make that
direct connection and like i said in
some instances things happened in the
opposite direction is what we would have
anticipated um so certainly something
that we will continue to watch and
certainly if we there are future
variants that are significant and
certainly have a you know hindering
impact on the economy that will be
something that we'll want to look into
in terms of revenues thank you very much
representative ames
yeah
a slightly a different uh question
is
i'm wondering about big business versus
smaller businesses and we've had a large
increase in revenue
that's i guess an understatement
but
query whether it's
the big businesses that are mostly
the source of that or
or smaller ones can you speak to that
sure so um
certainly if you're familiar with our
annual report in our triangles the
majority of our revenue comes from a few
number of businesses
i suspect that to continue to be the
case we will update our triangles at the
i know that you know during covid and we
talked about this that there were while
certain businesses were feeling a
negative impact from covid there were
some very large businesses that were
positively benefiting from the pandemic
a lot of that was kind of retail whether
online or brick or more brick and mortar
technology companies healthcare
companies so there were some winners
large winners during the pandemic i
suspect that the triangles will remain
where we the majority of our revenue and
much of the revenue growth is coming
from that bottom point but certainly
some of the factors we were talking
about in terms of you know unemployment
being able to hire that's really going
to i think impact your smaller
businesses more than your larger
businesses a smaller business doesn't
have as much cushion to absorb you know
when they need to hire three more people
and they can't find those people that's
a very different calculus than for a
large business that can maybe absorb
some higher vacancy rates so how these
various factors impact each business and
the size of the business varies and will
impact our revenue going forward but
once the fiscal year closes we will be
thank you on two things one i've got a
draft
uh
copy of the tax year 19 is that's what
is going to appear next or are we going
to be up to 20.
we should be at 20. oh good yep
um
but also
we're about
to start seeing the results of single
sales factor next year
correct
do you have on and we're in we've been
in market-based sourcing for
a full year we've been in market-based
sourcing for a full year so the first
returns that we're seeing for calendar
year taxpayers were filed in march and
april but as you all know they can
extend their return till the fall so it
won't be until october november until we
can fully digest those single sales
factor is in effect for calendar year
starting calendar year 2022 so it'll be
next spring when we start to get the
single sales factor returns and then we
can better analyze the impact but you
said that we'd have we'd get some idea
of what single sales factor would do to
us
from the market-based sourcing returns
correct so once we could be analyzable
before january
correct so once we have the returns with
market-based sourcing as
the sourcing methodology for services
and intangibles we can then move from
our three factor to single sales factor
so yes in the fall when we have closer
to a full batch if you will full
calendar year of returns we can start to
do an analysis
of if
calendar year 21
repeated itself exactly the same in
calendar 22 and the only difference was
the shift to single sales factor we'll
be able to start quantifying those
numbers correct
thank you but if i could just add uh
we'll be looking at a very atypical year
to a very atypical year that may be down
correct which is why i said if you if
you assume that
21 is exactly the same as 22 correct
okay representative schaumburg has a
question
thank you commissioner
uh
going to representative ames is
a
point of maybe about the corporations
and your description of the inverted
triangle
before i get to my question i just like
to say
there were 80 corporations that paid
over a million in bpt
as of 8 27 21
and 12 corporations that paid over a
million in bet
and then the next category was a hundred
thousand to a million
591 paying the bpt and 237 paying the
bet now my question is has the growth of
revenue in new hampshire been static in
the number of businesses contributing to
the bpt slash bet or has there been an
increase in the number of businesses
that have started doing business here in
new hampshire to cause this
revenue
i don't know for certain without all the
data in front of me but i suspect that
it is
unlikely
that there will be new business brand
new businesses coming into that point of
the triangle it's likely existing
businesses that are going to move in
move down the triangle if you will
towards the point
okay
um so estimates for
so
we as you may remember we run a variety
of kind of scenarios to estimate when
we're in a fiscal year how the fiscal
year will end so
for
fiscal year 22
we are assuming actual with prior year
for our scenario for business taxes so
what that means is we take actual
year-to-date revenue
and we are going to include actuals for
may and june
of last year and that arrives at the
1.19
billion
we arrived at that scenario because june
estimates are the largest source of
remaining revenue may is a typically a
pretty small revenue month but we have
business tax estimates q2 estimates due
in june and may and due revenue from
last year is roughly equal to the
typical increase that we see in q2
estimates from q1
typically first quarter estimates are
the lowest estimates out of the four
quarters for the year some taxpayers
they're aware of their credit carryover
for instance from the prior year
and so they may factor that that credit
carry over and reduce that first quarter
estimate so we typically see an increase
between q1 and q2 when you apply that
historic increase
it basically at this point subject to
change but at this point looks like our
june estimates will come in roughly the
same as last year
for fiscal year 23
we applied a 3.2
growth rate to our new fiscal 22
estimate and that 3.2 growth rate is the
growth rate that was in hb1 from fiscal
year 22 to 23. so we didn't change the
growth rate we just changed the base
that it's being applied to
you know year-to-date
with business taxes
we are seeing a pretty significant
year-over-year growth of
about 27 percent
so the 3.4 percent
assumes um a pretty substantial decrease
in the in your over here increase that
we've been seeing so we're not yet
projecting it to decrease we still think
there will be a small amount of growth
from 22 to 23 but obviously that may
change as things move forward in the
next few months
um from that
the fiscal year 22 grow
new fiscal year 22 estimate with a 3.2
percent growth rate we then subtracted
the surplus statement items that were
included in hb1 as well and so that
leaves you with the
1.16 billion for 23 which will be a 21.1
percent increase over plan so again even
though the growth rate is the same
because fiscal year 22 has performed so
well that increases how we anticipate we
will perform versus plan in 23.
okay
i guess the only other comment i make is
that
with the ukraine
war going on
it seems like we're we're providing a
lot of uh
defense
military support and we do have
companies like bae
who provide a lot of the
components that go into a lot of these
things so i i would imagine
this is
this will reflect next year's
their revenues certainly and this is
something we can't really talk about
individual companies but i just did but
but we can talk about the fact that i
think new hampshire has um
a fairly diverse um
base in terms of you know how we
generate our revenues in terms of
various industries
so we did fare better than some other
states in the early part of the pandemic
if you take a state like hawaii that's
primarily driven by tourism
um they saw significant impacts to their
revenues at the start of the pandemic we
have a tourism component to our economy
but we also have other industries that
performed well so i think our mix of
industries allows us to kind of weather
um changes in the economy better than
some other states so when we have you
know a defense industry that's
performing well that can help if another
industry is being negatively impacted by
whatever is going on
so that's a good segue to meals and
rooms tax great segue to meals and runs
tax
so historically the meals in rooms tax
is about 80 meals 17 rooms and 3 percent
motor vehicles
again the chart showing you fiscal year
20 revenue where you can see which is in
oh it's not colored for you it's the
first um line
on the left for each month you can see
in april may and june
the impact from covid initially
in 21 you can see
some impact over the winter and then
some recovery in the spring and then 22
we are performing fairly well compared
to 20. if you do notice that or excuse
me compared to 21 you will notice that
22 looks like it is performing below 21.
that is on a net basis and that's due to
the municipal revenue fund transfer
so
we are now um
distributing to municipalities 30
percent
of the m revenue that's collected that
goes on a monthly basis into a dedicated
fund
so when you
you'll see
under factors to consider we're 54.6
million or almost 20 percent ahead of
plan
but we're 4 million 4.7 million or 1.8
percent below prior year and that's
because of the impact of the municipal
um
revenue fund transfer next year when
we're comparing 23 to 22 you'll have an
apples-to-apples comparison you'll have
two years with the municipal fund
transfer
um
yeah i think we're going to have a
little bit of discussion on all these
transfers a little later on yep coming
um we are as i mentioned um
to representative tucker with her
question we're receiving or we're
experiencing a bit of return to normal
after our initial covet impacts um when
things were shut down we've kind of come
back to pre-covered levels if not above
pre-coded levels
inflation and cost of meals
will continue to be something that we
will watch
as well as hiring ability to hire in the
sort of hospitality industry it is
difficult currently if it gets worse
that could also potentially impact
the revenue that we receive i know there
are some restaurants on main street that
aren't open for lunch because they just
can't get the people
to staff both a lunch and a dinner um so
that is something that we'll need to
watch
and then as representative abrami
mentioned there's two transfers that
come out of m r each month first is the
school building aid transfer and the
second on page six is the municipal
revenue fund transfer that i mentioned
we'll provide details about both of
those transfers on the subsequent pages
but when we look to estimate m r revenue
we add back in the municipal fund
transfer and we add back in the school
building aid transfer because that is
money that we've collected
we then apply the growth rate and then
subtract out the transfer amounts so
that um
we appropriately account for any
positive or negative growth on all of
the revenue that we've received
so where do we think m r is going to end
22 um
we are assuming that the percent that
we've been above plan will remain for
the next two months um year to date we
are i had a plan by 26.9
and we will anticipate that same
increase for the next two months
generally throughout 20 fiscal year 22
we've been roughly 20 to 30 percent
ahead of plan um so that 26.9 is right
in that range and again this is net of
that municipal fund transfer
for fiscal for fiscal 23 um we kept the
same 5 growth over 22 that we assumed in
hb1
um as i mentioned that's applied to the
new gross fiscal year 22 growth gross
estimate and then we removed seven
million dollars for the school building
aid transfer
120.1 million for the municipal transfer
and then there was a surplus statement
item um
relative to the m rate change of 19
million
that rate change went into effect in
october of 20
october
of fiscal 22 so we didn't have a full
year impact yet so we account for the
remainder of that input
on page seven this is the school
building aid transfer
basically there's a portion of m r every
year that we then divide into every
month that is
to pay bonds for school building aid and
so the amount this started in 2010
um
and the amount has been a high of 14 and
a half million in fiscal year 2012.
in fiscal year 22 it's just under 8.1
million and in fiscal 23 it'll be just
over 7 million
so
this is a dedicated amount that comes
out every month but like i said we
include it
we add it back in before we apply any
growth estimates because it's just a
portion of the revenue so this is
already netted out though when you see
on page eight this is the municipal fund
transfer this was in hb2 uh the last of
last year
so treasury distributes m revenue to
cities and towns
equal to 30 percent
uh every year
but we put revenue into this fund on a
monthly basis
and so what you can see here in the
chart is the monthly amounts that are
put in um during fiscal year 22 and the
reason why the amount changes each month
is so that it kind of tracks with how
revenue performs each month so if it's a
lower revenue month we will put less
into the municipal
revenue fund
and then this amount will update each
year based on the revenue received in
the prior year because it is 30
of the revenue that will go to cities
if there's no other
value
yeah just checking so what you're saying
is that
at the beginning of the year using the
plan which didn't work
you decide how much money each month is
going to go
yes so at the beginning of the year
we will know the amount that will go and
so we will split it over the course of
the months and over the years over the
year yep and it'll like i said track
with revenues so that we don't take an
unequal hit to general fund revenue in a
month where revenues are low we'll do a
smaller transfer but yeah we determine
all that at the beginning suddenly
because of for instance the
the weather
on
march
is a great month it will still be
be the amount that was shed at the
beginning of the year correct
correct right we set the amounts at the
beginning year we try to track it
towards general performance um
but it is it won't be adjusted um when
and again this is what you see in the
revenue focus is net of this transfer
can you can you explain one more time uh
on the the we we did reduce the rate and
do they want to put effect in
january
of 0.5 percent
so that shows in the surplus statement
is that what i'm reading here yes how
does that work again so when you're
estimating revenues at the time
of the budget you're estimating them
based on current law
and so because of
the rate change we had a surplus
statement item in 23. and so we've
included that here because even though
we're using 22 as our base that
rate change impact is not fully
accounted for in that year because it
happened part way through the year
on to the next okay tobacco tax
okay so tobacco tax is um not based on
or made up of 90
of cigarette stamps so that's a stamp
that goes on the bottom of each package
of cigarettes and then 10 from other
tobacco products so that can be
your loose tobacco um that also now
includes e-cigarettes
so again you can see the chart of the
you may remember that during covid we
saw a pretty
that was
i think due to a couple of reasons
um one generally the conditions of the
pandemic early on
were
stressful and maybe not the most
conducive to folks that were trying to
um smoke less
also you'll see under factors to
consider there is a ban in massachusetts
of all flavor tobacco products so we
have seen an increase here in new
hampshire
of mentholated cigarettes in particular
as well as other flavored tobacco
products as people kind of come across
the border from massachusetts to
purchase products here that they cannot
purchase
in massachusetts
fiscal year to date we are 5.2 percent
below plan um
or 10.6 million and we are
14 million or 6.8 percent below prior
year
fiscal year to date through april stamp
sales are 7 below
but above 20 by 8 percent so what i
think is happening is that
when we made when we built plan
we were anticipating that this
kind of high water mark from covid was
going to continue
and instead we see it tracking back to
as representative almirae remember our
normal trend of about a three to five
percent decrease year over year so we're
still ahead of where we were
pre-pandemic but we are starting to
track um that normal decrease that we
see in year-over-year
reduction in tobacco
i just want to comment that's
it's
it's just a coincidence that we're down
10.6 million but the tobacco settlement
came in 10.8 more we're going to be
tobacco is neutral
yeah
thank you
very much
yeah i'm trying i don't remember when
they banned the men's up saw
but
i think that's about right
yeah it was the end of calendar 2020.
so we're
we're past a full year now i'm wondering
if we could look at how much
massachusetts is losing
in its tobacco tax versus how much we're
losing
i may have that
because they could also be
finally getting off of menthol
cigarettes
they yeah and that's going to be my next
point so um massachusetts is down about
based on data i had back in february
um but from from the year that included
pre-ban yeah yes
um
but that leads to my next point which is
we all might be experiencing
this ban if it happens at a federal
level so
the federal government is considering a
national ban on menthol cigarettes and
flavored cigars this is on the top of
page 10. it is expected to be proposed
by the fda by the end of this calendar
year and that it would have an effective
date a year later so we would be looking
at january roughly january of 24 as a
potential
um
start of when
mentholated products
and flavored products would not be
available to anyone so that is something
we are going to watch closely because we
would need to factor that into
our revenue estimates for the next
biennium so we have not at this point
because it's still it's anticipated but
it hasn't been proposed and there's not
you know details on timing but that is
something that that we'll watch closely
so is this going to be through federal
legislation or okay yep this is is that
in the hopper or is it
i don't
know exactly how close to the top or
bottom however works um but it it is
suspected that we may have a proposal
um by the fda by the end of this
calendar year and then it takes about a
year from that point once it's been
formally proposed by the fda it would be
a year before it went into effect yeah
that'll be a double whammy for us
because we the massachusetts correct
correct so we would lose not only our
own revenue on mentholated and flavored
products but then the increase that
we've seen in the past few years from
massachusetts
yes so it has to go through congress
no just fda oh okay yep
yeah i thought you were saying congress
oh no i'm sorry i mean
it's not it's just fda just yeah that's
my understanding
of what it is let's assume there's well
in two years if there's an
administration change could that turn
back
yeah
correct
oh rip is in line
so two things effectively on the
flavored ban was june 1st of 2020
and
this also looks like let two bills in
massachusetts illustration to repeal
that ban
and take and allow flavor tobacco again
you know do you i always have to either
no
doesn't say just so that there's two
bills
to repeal the uh 2018
um tobacco got it i i always ask you
that question is is that what's going on
in mass and
i decided not to ask that question this
time because i assumed nothing but
that was good
represent tucker
there is no attraction in massachusetts
okay but i think it's important to
mention that the reason that ventilated
uh and flavored uh cigarettes are being
considered for repeal is that
it has been
a
policy of tobacco companies
to target
black neighborhoods and there's a very
much higher
use of these cigarettes with the
resultant
health
consequences
and earlier deaths are shown in the
mortality figures so this is a very
this isn't really a revenue
issue alone this has to do with general
health
of people in the united states and
whether they're in our neighboring state
or whether they're in this state
we need to hope that more people will
not smoke
it has
very
bad effects on the human body and it
costs a great deal of money and that is
why we get the money
is because there's costs
to
treating people
who are affected by tobacco use
and we've mentioned before too
we
the majority of the cigarettes that we
sell in this state are not consumed by
people in this state we have the lowest
tax rate of the neighboring of all of
our surrounding states um and so we are
a large exporter of of cigarettes um
so we'll certainly watch um what a
if and when a federal ban may come into
effect
but these amounts are assuming no ban
so for fiscal year 22
we
are assuming that the um negative 5.2
percent that we've experienced year to
date compared to plan will continue for
may and june
and then for fiscal year 23 we apply to
negative 3 growth again that is the
original growth rate from
hb1
so
the reason why it's not the five percent
is i do think we're kind of normalizing
a little bit which is why we're seeing
that significant decrease i don't think
it's necessarily going to decrease
another five percent but it will kind of
temper and go back to that three percent
that we typically see year to year
um and that's generally like i said what
we saw before covid okay
next is interest and dividends tax um
interest and dividends is made up of
41.5 from distributions
from dividend income
two percent from interest income and
seven point three four percent from
federally tax-exempt income so that's
income that's exempt federally but not
exempt here in new hampshire
um you'll see in the chart interest and
dividends on the majority of our revenue
comes in in april
um so through april uh year to date we
are 19.6 or 16.9 percent ahead of plan
and 24.4 million or 22 percent ahead of
prior year
ind can fluctuate pretty significantly
year to year it's a volatile tax um
there's a lot of things that make up how
the tax performs as i mentioned it's not
just interest in dividends distributions
are a significant portion of the revenue
and as representative almy mentioned
earlier if businesses choose to issue
higher amounts of distributions than
they have historically that would have a
positive impact here on ind
obviously we are watching interest rates
we're watching the fluctuations um in
the stock market as those tend to be
indicators maybe not uh direct
tracking of but tend to be indicators of
how ind performs
on page 12 just a reminder the ind tax
is set to be repealed so we are going
through a number of rate reductions that
is starting with a one percent reduction
to four percent for taxable periods
ending on or after december 31st of 23
you see that that goes to three percent
for 24 2 for 25 1 for 26 and then it's
fully repealed for taxable periods
beginning after december 31st of 2026.
so we are in a decline of ind
um
[Music]
yeah
45 41.5 percent distribution in 2020
when things were not so good
on
and what i was just talking about that
that on
they say that
that uh
over i think it was 54
of
the net profits had gone to the owners
last year
um
no distribution would go to anybody that
was earning
under
50 000 a year
this
on
so that part of this is only a tax on
and dividend income is partially
interested partially
so and that's a good point as you know
things change potentially with
distributions as things change with the
interest rate um as things change with
the stock market and potentially
dividends received from there this
breakdown of what makes up ind
can shift from year to year and as we
get into more revenue estimating into
the fall we can talk about how that has
kind of shift
how that makeup has changed over time
and we may want to consider looking at
that as we're developing revenue
estimates
um for fiscal year 22 we are assuming
that our percent versus plan
will remain
through the last two months of may and
june we did have some anomalous payments
that we've received year-to-date so
we've removed those so that we don't
artificially inflate the growth rate so
without the anomalous payments that
we've received we're only about 1.1
percent ahead of plan um so that's what
we're anticipating for may and june
and then for 23 we assumed the same 3
growth rate that was in the original hb1
applied to the new revenue estimate for
22 and then removed the impact of the um
surplus statement items for the decrease
in the ind tax which will start to phase
out and we will start to feel the
so again another tax to keep your eye on
as the um things going on in the market
and in the economy could potentially um
have an impact here
okay i got it
i want one comment our question have you
looked at you know 401ks were a
phenomenon that started somewhere my
mid-career
um
now i'm i have to take distributions
right
and they're taxable right that's delayed
taxing on their 401 concept
but i as that as the population ages
there's going to be a lot more of that
going on that people are going to do i
know when i
put my ind i have taken to a fact that i
got a distribution
uh that's that's taxable
um
so i just throw that out
i we haven't tried to quantify that
specifically but that's certainly
something we're probably going to see in
a trend and we'll see if we look at the
breakdown of ind based on the various
factors from year to year and to your
point you might see a greater shift
towards distributions when the economy
is doing well with an aging population
there could be a number of things that
potentially impact
that makeup of that pie of ind revenue
thank you
and they they raised the year uh they
gave a year
more before you have to take that
distribution and i would think that that
likely
will happen again this is a very popular
um
thing to do for people who have money
and so very quietly they've added a year
so you have to be 71 and a half now
rather than 70 and a half to start
taking minimum
distribution right
yeah correct and so that i think looking
that's something some are still taking
like i i took it anyway i d but anyway
but
i'm just me but
with bursting i just they're required to
talk
yeah they're required right it's
required yeah part
right and there was a little they they
put a hold on that
right
now there's more than wealthy wealthy
people who are
i mean
has
i mean defined benefit plans are have
been reduced significantly i think not
many employees have defined benefit
plans anymore
they're pretty much 401 to find
contribution plans these days
and i think and that that includes all
levels of people salaries people so
anyway
or they might not get them right
with companies that do offer
pension plans
um that's the case
okay moving on to communication services
tax
so at the chart at the top of the page
you'll notice
um
in revenue that's a bit of a timing
issue it's an anomaly um so just wanted
to point point that out because it's
somewhat obvious um for fiscal year 21.
so factors to consider with cst so we
are 7.1 million or 22 percent below plan
8.1 million or 24.3 below prior year
this tax has
he has had years of fluctuation then we
had some time it was performing pretty
consistently now we're getting into some
bit of fluctuation so
some things that have happened recently
that impact this tax the taxability of
video conferencing and the increased use
of that product
over
um the pandemic we've seen increased use
of video conferencing so that kind of
has a positive impact on
cst
the ongoing reduction in landlines
we've mentioned that for years so that
has a negative effect on cst
we've talked about how you know
landlines have reduced but we had seen a
shift to wireless right so in my
household we don't have a landline but
my husband and i both have cell phones
so you kind of trade two for one um
the wireless market is
getting a bit more saturated we're not
seeing
that you know significant increase
in
the wireless market that we had seen in
the past right so for a number of years
more and more people were getting cell
phones
now most grown adults have a cell phone
or if they don't maybe they're not going
to get one and it's really just
the kids the younger
kids kind of coming on
um
with cell phones and so maybe as people
are tapering off and younger kids are
coming on it's not having that same
growth that we kind of saw for years
with wireless
um the other thing to note
that i think is what's happening at
least somewhat recently which is
potentially
impacting our
[Music]
decrease in cst revenue is that wireless
service providers
and how they bifurcate the amount that
they charge you for voice versus the
amount that they charge you for data
so
voice is the only thing that's taxable
under cst
your data on your wireless bill is not
we did tax internet access years ago we
do not um under cst anymore
so
as wireless providers kind of change
how that that split between voice and
data is accounted for on customers bills
that can have an impact on the amount of
cst that we receive
i for one don't talk on my cell phone
very much
it's a lot of either texts or using it
for email um and so i think you know in
particular if my wireless provider
looked at how much i was actually using
it for two-way communication for voice
it would be much less than what i'm
using it for other types of
communication so i i think the the shift
in how customers are being billed by
their wireless providers is starting to
impact the amount of cst that we're
collecting
yeah i do talk on my cell phone a lot
i'm paying less in tax
than i did when i had a landline only
and
uh but i'm wondering about
are you
collecting for video conferencing
we are um and that is as that kind of i
think we've talked about this before as
that um
method of communication
uh became more prevalent um we have
audit programs related to that and so
we're making sure um that we are
collecting um the tax that's due on
those services
so and
on what basis
i mean
there are the people that get licenses
so that they can run zone conferences
and then there are people who just use
them that if i remember correctly don't
pay anything
right so the tax is on what you pay um
it's a portion of
what you pay so
free
products may not have a tax associated
with it because it needs we need to
apply the tax rate to some sort of base
but again that is another thing that may
fluctuate over time
i think there was a lot of free options
available early in the pandemic when
folks were starting to use this product
and now folks have realized it is a very
valuable product and maybe they are
willing to pay for it and so we may see
that shift occur as well so it's it's
just something else that we will need to
continue to monitor um with respect to
this test
we taxed the license
to the extent that it's two-way
communication that's taxable under cst
correct
so you outreach to all these different
companies we have our ways of
consciousness oh i can imagine
okay
yeah if if i could
i've got a license i don't know why i
have a license i'm thinking that i may
have to run a meeting at some point
but on i get charged a flat 150 a year
they don't say anything about taxes
so i can't comment on specific products
or specific vendors but it it is
something that we are consider when we
are reviewing um the various products
that are available on the market well
they they may the company may choose to
absorb that right and not show it to the
potentially correct yeah thank you
so with cst we are assuming for the rest
of this year that our performance
against plan will be sustained and then
um we're assuming
that 22 to 23 will be relatively flat we
do have um some credit carryovers that
are being utilized and so we've taken
those into account um
in our 23 estimates but my suspicion is
that you know hopefully this this tax is
kind of kind of level out
page 15 real estate transfer tax
oh boy okay um so
the first thing i would point out is on
the chart at the top
fiscal year 22 plan is going to be
the line furthest to the right in each
of the months
if you look at that
you will see that we anticipated
a decrease
um to occur if you look at february
march april
we really kind of anticipated a low
point in march
we just haven't seen it um plan this
year anticipated a three percent
year-over-year reduction over prior year
we back-loaded that three percent into
the plan figuring that the year would
start strong but once the winter months
hit we would start to see that decrease
in rent that we anticipated
obviously that didn't happen um so
we are 31.1 million or 19 ahead of plan
we are 26.9 million or 16 ahead of prior
year
again these amounts are net of the five
million dollar transfer to the
affordable housing fund that is a new
transfer
two years ago
that happens every october in october we
send five million dollars to the
affordable housing fund
things that are impacting rent so
inventory shortage we know all know that
that exists but prices are still making
up for that reduction of inventory so
we're seeing fewer transactions but
they're happening at a much higher price
so
the real estate transfer tax continues
new hampshire association of realtors
reported that last month's supply of
inventory was an 11 decrease from last
year
i would have thought last year was a
pretty low month into you know low time
in terms of real estate inventory this
is even lower
um the same group publishes a new
hampshire housing affordability index
i'm on the top of page 16
which measures housing affordability for
the region so as an example of index of
120 means that household income is 120
of what is necessary to qualify for a
median priced home
under the prevailing interest rates
march 2020
at an affordability index of 80 had the
lowest month in the last year on the
affordability index for single family
homes so basically median income is not
enough money you're not making enough
money
to
qualify
for
a median price home at the current
interest rates
but houses continue to sell um so
i think this is just
it's
a bit of a ticking time bomb i don't
think it's necessarily going to explode
but at some point we're going to see a
decrease we're just the the prices um
people are not going to be able to
afford them and so the lack of inventory
in the higher prices are not going to
i'm sorry i misspoke
yeah
any other questions that just might
yeah and the realtors keep on saying
that it's a fairly very small percentage
of the people that are buying these
incredibly expensive houses
on that come from out of state
but there's been some uh
controversy about
on whether they really are from out of
state but had been vacationing here or
something like that
uh
so
do you i think that the new hampshire
finance
housing finance authority has been
trying to
to figure out how to look at this do you
know whether there's anything because
that on
new hampshire given the climate in the
west for instance
is apparently one of the targets for
very rich people trying to move
somewhere else
[Music]
and has been for some time for some of
them just for tax purposes
and
have you
kept up with
what they're doing on trying to figure
this out i have not um
i imagine that
that is probably different for the
various regions across the state
um obviously there are some locations
either
you know closer to massachusetts it's
easier for someone to massachusetts to
move across the border you also have
vacation areas of the state like the
lakes region which might be more
conducive or more
likely to have someone move from out of
state but that might not be the same for
the north country for instance it might
be less likely in representative
tucker's district for someone to move
from out of state so i think it may vary
um
you know we're just tracking kind of
what's been happening with the
purchasing of the homes and the tax
associated with it and haven't
necessarily looked into as much as who's
buying them or why they're buying them
necessarily
um the median sales price was up 20 and
a half percent to 440 000 for a single
family home
and up 30.9 to 350 and a half thousand
for condos in march of 22. so
the median home price and condo price is
quite high
for new hampshire based on our history
um another factor to consider is that
morgan mortgage rates are rising
they were five and a half percent for a
30-year fixed on may 4th
and that was above the 52 week low of
2.8 percent so with interest rates
they're rising quite quickly
at some of the highest mortgage rates
we've seen in quite a while
um so we'll have to wait and see i think
on the impact of what the mortgage rates
have on the housing market um presumably
there will be one um but i think we're
gonna have to wait a little bit to see
how that pans out
so for fiscal year 22 we are assuming
that we our performance versus prior
year through april will continue for may
and june as i mentioned we had kind of
back loaded a decrease in the plan so i
didn't want to use our comparison to
plan numbers because those might have
been artificially inflated due to how we
set the monthly revenue plan so instead
we're just looking at how we're
performing versus prior year for 22
and then for 23 we assumed a negative
three percent growth
that was the original
impact that we thought we were going to
see this year
since we didn't see that this year we
just bumped it out a year maybe we'll
see it next year we got to see it one of
these days so just bumped it out of here
um
but fiscal year 23 plan had assumed an 8
decrease over fiscal 22.
so that's why and that chart at the top
when you look at the revised 23 estimate
of 228 million that looks like 25.3
percent ahead of plan
that's because that plan is a negative
three percent with a negative eight
percent on top of it we never even saw
the negative three percent never mind
the negative eight so that's why that's
looking like plan is very or our
estimate is very high compared to plan
so
my best thought at this point is just
move that three percent to the next year
and then we might be the eight percent
the year after um because we're just in
record territory for the real estate
transfer tax representative tucker well
certainly in the north country and i
think in the rest of the state
we've had a tremendous uh
a number of people who are able to work
remotely
so there's a relationship i believe
between broadband and its expansion
which is being heavily promoted
and
and where people can live
and it's made an enormous difference in
the north country we have some areas
that have very good connection others
that don't but where people can work
remotely
many are and it has really affected the
real estate transfer tax that's a great
very connected yes agreed agreed and i
you know it sounds like remote work is
here to stay um
at least at some level
um
so i think that is something to continue
to watch as more and more people are
able to work remotely that might be a
driver for people from other states to
come
the last thing i will mention on
the real estate transfer tax is the land
and community heritage investment
program or l-chip
so l-chip is a 25 fee that's charged for
the recording of each deed mortgage
mortgage discharge or plan that are
recorded at the registry
l-chip funds are paid to the counties
along with the ret each month and then
transfer to the l-chip program
so it is
unlike the other transfers that we
talked about
um
we don't include l-chip apply the growth
rate and then remove l-chip because it's
we're just really the pass-through for
that money the counties are already
sending us money so they just include
l-chip with it and we pass it on
um
so it functions a little bit differently
in our estimating of
the other how we handle the other
transfers
because it just goes to altitude it just
goes it doesn't stop at the general fund
anywhere it keeps on going right thank
you
and if l-chip didn't exist this wouldn't
exist
or if it didn't get transferred to
l-chip the general fund wouldn't keep it
right so in the other instances like the
municipal fund if that didn't exist the
general fund would just keep that money
so that's why we add it back in okay
thank you represent bursting yeah thank
you lindsey
so 25 fees are charged
um
i'm the bottom line is i'm getting to
refinancing mortgages which i think is
going to drop dramatically but when
someone refinances a mortgage that's
fifty dollars to l chip because they
retire the old mortgage which is a 25
fee and then a new mortgage so 50
dollars every time
and with rates going up
refines are going to
drop decrease yep so chip can expect so
that's something that l-chip will need
to factor into their future revenue
estimates all right just make sure you
any other questions on
red
no okay okay we're on to one
utility property tax
you'll see in the chart at the top of
the page on page 17 um it really comes
in a few times a year in the form of
estimates um we have returns due in
january so that can be a little bit of a
higher month
but basically non-estimate months are
either early or late payments
um year-to-date where 2.3 million or 7.4
percent i had a plan or 2.7 million or
8.8 percent ahead of prior year the
increase is primarily due to increased
valuations in fiscal year 22 and
taxpayers using up some ccos in prior
years so we've seen an increase in
utility property valuations
recently
some property values may decline though
given various economic conditions new
taxable property on the top of page 18
can always be constructed so it's a
little bit of a volatile tax that we
keep our eye on
it is roughly around 40 to 45 million
dollars a year and it is uh solely
dedicated to the education trust fund
so we suspect that um our sustaining
performance versus prior year will be
will continue through may and june which
was an 8.8 increase over prior year
again primarily due to the increase in
valuations that we saw recently
and then
um
i'm anticipating a flat growth from 22
to 23 just given some of the
uncertainties
in in the market especially with fuel
prices
it will be interesting to see kind of
what happens with with the various
properties so
just to be conservative i've left it
representative schamberg
thank you mr chairman
commissioner
this utility property tax
i've heard that eversource is going to
make bids on buying all utility poles
uh in new hampshire
would that affect this
this uh
tax if it goes private
so these are going to
the utilities that are taxed here are
the the impact i think that you're
referring to may have something to do
with the trimming of the trees
okay and um and the cost to do so
um that is more likely to impact i think
the um i mean at the municipal level um
with the
transmission
at the municipal level i don't i don't
know necessarily actually the impact for
statewide or at the municipal level
until there's greater detail but
i'm not sure that who owning it
necessarily would impact the value
but i
am somewhat familiar with what you're
so those are our estimates at this point
in time subject to change potentially
tomorrow um
we're in you know an interesting time i
think just in terms of how strong
revenues have been performing
um
and i think that we just need to to
watch the various factors
um
and then also it'll be important as we
get into revenue estimating like i said
in the
fall to think about the timing of the
various taxes right
real estate transfer tax we get that on
a monthly basis m r we get that on a
monthly basis it's very quick to see the
impacts of things that may be happening
in the economy there's a delayed impact
with ind and business taxes and so
that'll be something that we need to
watch and we may potentially need to
factor in something that we think is
going to happen that we might not be
seeing in the revenues to date so
fun times ahead
now um
lindsay we have uh
chris we have this other dot handout and
and it talks there's a few areas that
are
uh dra and then the others are liquor
just what was on the top of the
spread
crochet lba so reps on bromine that is
correct there's a document titled
revenue sources with restricted revenue
transfers and associated statutes it's
kind of a
dull cover page
there's several that are dra collected
then there's the liquor transfers and
then one that i didn't identify but it's
in the rsa is the transfer that occurs
the second to last page
uh roman 1d
so that it was written into the statute
that any of the insurance premium tax
that's collected that's associated with
basically medicaid expansion would go
into the granite advantage fund i failed
to highlight that on on this document
but insurance will present that as part
of their discussion today you'll see it
as one of the back outs that they
provide
so represent major had asked about these
a few weeks ago and he asked that i
provide you with these
documents today just so you'd have it
and then i asked the uh the various
agencies coming before you to discuss
those transfers as they as they came
through right i think some of the
confusion sometimes happens when you get
the various reports from agencies
throughout the month the daily revenues
from our office
daily revenues from dra and then daily
revenues from administrative services
those are much on a cash basis and it's
not until the end of the month that
those are typically um
uh account for the transfers
and then you get your revenue focus and
the revenue focus if if you don't mind
i'll just take a second because i'm not
sure how many people are with the
revenue focus
but it's a very
good document for quick information
related to your general fund education
trust fund revenues your fish and game
revenues and your highway fund revenues
so on the front page would give you a
table that has your current month plan
and your actuals
on the on the
right hand side actually in the
left-hand side and then on the
right-hand side would be brief snippets
of what happened that month with that
revenue source and the various agencies
responsible for collecting that revenue
work with administrative services to
provide those brief narratives as to
what occurred in that month
and then as you flip the page you're
going to find all sorts of
tables charts
and information
um earlier there was a question around
the business tax refunds from
representative ames
on page two in the middle of the page is
a chart there that shows you for the
last three years what the business tax
refunds have looked like so it gives you
a quick review of what's going on what
happened in the last month that you've
just completed
um above that you have the m r analysis
that shows you your gross collection
shows you the two transfers out of that
fund
and it shows it on the month basis and
then on a year-to-date basis
so throughout this document there's a
lot of good information and as you get
to the second to last page you have a
table of the general education funds
and it's the year to date
so it gives you what the plan amount is
year to date and then what the actual
collections are year to date
and so just gives you a good reference
point at the end of each month as to
where you are with your various um
revenues let's use that as an example
though for the general discussion here
is that but these are
this is from administrative services
their report that is correct this is
administrative services net of
all of these some statutes yes right
that the money comes off the top before
it gets reported here exactly
my my question's always been is
maybe i'm okay with that in terms of
well you may want to explain the way you
explained it to me the other day
but
it's
i just want to make sure when i look at
actual plan that i'm looking apples to
apples
you know you know that
that the plan was based on money coming
out as well that's correct so can you
just spend a second on that so i mean uh
commissioner steph had mentioned you
know in terms of some of their um
estimates they put back in the transfers
and then
figure out what their growth would be
and then they back that out after and in
some instances there's things that are
done as part of the surplus statement so
we account for
all the transfers or reductions or
additions that might occur to revenue
during the budget building process
so as you may recall when you're doing
your revenue estimates
for the unrestricted revenue it's on
current law and there may be bills going
through that are going to change
a tax or or add a tax or
a fee somewhere and so we account for
that as part of the surplus statement
and then at the end of the
budget process when everything's signed
off administrative services will work
with the agencies to come up with a
monthly revenue plan
and that's what they track through their
revenue focus
so
so you do get an apples-to-apples
comparison i think where you get an
apples-to-oranges comparison is when
you're looking at the daily revenues
each month because not everything is
backed out it's on a cash basis so when
you get a report from me
unless i've noted to you for instance
with the m r that i back that out of the
number we haven't backed out the real
estate transfer to l-chip we haven't
backed out
the
liquor you know if there's a transfer
related to going to the granite
advantage or the alcohol commission fund
that doesn't happen to the end of the
month
every day the revenues are changing on a
daily basis
and for that reason we don't try to be
precise until the close of the month
otherwise it's a a lot of potential for
misinformation going back and forth
so we just stay to the cash basis during
the daily revenues and it's true also
with administrative services
and
dra you know they give you what they've
collected on a cash basis
um
and if you get the administrative
services daily report it's essentially
this table the year-to-date table
and then a month to date table and if
you ever look at that you'll notice that
the education um trust fund account
during the month
is it looks like there's a lot of
negatives there there's not money that
hasn't been attributed to it yet it's
because the splits haven't occurred yet
those occur from you know the business
taxes the meals and rooms tax the real
estate transfer tax that all occurs at
the end of the month when the month is
closed because there could be a refund
for instance of dra on the you know the
29th of the month that would change a
split if they had done it early
so hopefully that helps but it
really i just wanted to say the revenue
focus is is your best
if you want to get a sense of where your
revenues are that's the best place to
look at that
thank you i do think that
uh
other than this committee and possibly
the one in the senate
i don't think anybody pays attention to
the fact that
revenues
may actually be going up but are being
spent
by the budget
on before any place else in the budget
gets it with these these
restricted transfers
and it seems to me that there ought to
at least be an asterisk
that the das does on the taxes that
that
whose revenues are reduced by specific
on
budgeted requirements over the years
so that people don't think oh we're
we're getting less from meals and rooms
i think that would be discussion with
administrative services on how they
would notate their um report because it
is their report yeah
we may want to invite them in at some
because this to us this is our bible
here and we want to and then when you go
back 10 years you know you want to try
to track how the revenues really did and
then if there's all of a sudden you
can't you can't right
even they're having trouble doing it
right right
okay um we got a few minutes um
do you have any comments on in the
handout there's there's a couple of
departments that are yours but i know
you touched on it already
do you have anything else you want to
add to that
no i think we covered it um i did double
check chris's numbers ties to what i had
in the report okay that's good
so
all right
so but this is a i would keep this
document it's a handy guide we
actually shows every statute where this
this is occurring and i think this is
valuable to have
for us
all right no other questions uh thank
you chris thank you lindsay very much
and we have uh next we have the
department of justice
and we have uh warren cormack and i
guess he has someone else with him but
and uh as as you probably know we have
one
simple question
you know we used to around 40 million
ish and all of a sudden it hit 50 uh on
the uh
tobacco settlement money so we're just
kind of curious what happened there
so if you want to both introduce
my name is warren cormack i'm an
attorney at the department of justice in
the consumer protection bureau i'm
tasked with tobacco enforcement
uh with me it's brandon grodd
senior assistant attorney general
brandon groud i'm the chief of the
consumer protection anti-trust bureau at
thanks for giving me the opportunity to
speak today
thank you for coming
so
i am tasked with diligent enforcement of
the tobacco statutes
and my understanding is you're asking me
uh why the payment was different from
the original estimates significantly
different significant if it was a
million either way we would not you know
we're just curious so every year
we receive estimates for
the eventual payments that will be made
under the msa
that's the master settlement agreement
this
is based on a calculation that relies on
several variables it relies on the
volume of cigarettes sold it relies on
inflation
it relies on the percentage market share
of certain types of tobacco companies
and
a lot of those variables are really
difficult to predict
so we provide an estimate based on the
anticipated
percentage
share based on the volume
based on the profits that tobacco
companies will make
and
and ultimately when we do report those
estimates we report them as rough
estimates because it's very difficult to
predict a lot of these variables
this year
several of the variables were much
different more different than
anticipated for example
inflation regularly is set to a three
percent floor in the calculation
but this past year it was over seven
percent that's never happened before
since the signing of the master
settlement agreement because of that the
the payment was raised by a significant
degree
also the profits that tobacco companies
are making
have increased also a significant amount
and that correction regularly
will be we'll add zero dollars but this
year it added
a lot of money to the payment so those
are two major factors
a third factor is what's called the npm
adjustment
and so what happens in this adjustment
is that
the
tobacco companies can withhold certain
amounts from payment
if they contest
charges uh that they owe the states
and this year we anticipated that they
might with help hold some money from the
states
and they ended up not doing so and we
received the entirety
of the payment that would be due under
the npm adjustment
and those disputes are related to
shifts in market share
across the tobacco industry
so those are the three major
contributors to why the payout was so
different than
was originally anticipated what was the
middle one again sorry it's inflation
and the next one was what the next one
is it's it's called the profit
adjustment and actually
it's an upward adjustment of a downward
adjustment so it ends up increasing
the payment but functionally it's
decreasing the payment less
because there's a volume adjustment that
decreases the payment every year for
the
volume of cigarettes which decrease
every year and then the profit
adjustment bumps it back up if the
tobacco companies are selling less
cigarettes but making more profit
we're not complaining actually
i've given it so
maybe a little bit different if we was a
10 million the other way
but um you know because i've been here
12 years and
this is the first time it's been that's
much of a variance but it sounds like
the perfect storm of these three things
occurring at the same time that's what
what causing this that's exactly right
and a lot of it is attributable to covet
yes um
as i recall the mppm adjustment it was
mostly centered around contesting lack
of enforcement by the states
and
your predecessor spent
a lot of time on
for
years
on going through the process of
of
tell getting them to understand that we
were enforcing properly and everybody
else had to
produce data that they were enforcing
properly is this lack of contest mostly
that
that they finally finished that process
it's an ongoing process and uh
ultimately
it just means that we were dispersed uh
the funds that
might otherwise have been sent to a
disputed payments account so
every year we need to diligently enforce
the statutes that level the playing
field between the signatories to the
master settlement agreement and the
non-signatories to the master settlement
agreement and
what a dispute is is it's a tobacco
company saying
claiming that they don't owe certain
funds
under that
diligent enforcement standard
and
this year they didn't make disputes that
we thought they might make
so it's not so much of a reflection
on diligent enforcement as it is on the
tobacco company's
uh
willingness to dispute
certain uh
aspects of diligent enforcement so they
can withhold that money and they they
did not so they might start that up
again next year yes yeah and that can
happen any year and
it's very difficult to predict what they
but
would you say that the projections when
you come here next january or
as we do our revenue projections
it's going to probably settle back that
you're probably going to come in
settling back down to the 40 million ish
or more
or less
so the current projections for the
upcoming year is at 40 million i
submitted a memo and i believe that was
the number in that memo
again whenever we give an estimate
i'd like to emphasize that it is a rough
estimate because it's so difficult to
predict all these variables
let me just one other thought so it's
part you you said something about colvin
so
are you saying that
we theorized that did more people smoke
during that period
that's exactly right
more people smoke
and uh more people
might shift to more premium cigarettes
when they do smoke
any of those factors would raise it the
inflation also has raised it and whether
that's attributable to covert or not i
can't speak to but
that's also a factor in the aftermath
that has raised the payment
okay thank you
any other questions oh representative
tucker
representative carmelo and i had a bill
that got sort of shifted aside because
of the pandemic
and it disappeared
in the process as happened to so many of
us
with bills
that
spring
but it had to do with finding out
whether we're really spending the money
effectively
for prevention
of starting smoking so it would be
rather than on the end
of getting people who were
smokers getting them to quit
it would be focused to see whether we're
properly focusing on those who have not
yet started smoking which as we know
and
that
disappeared
but is there a chance to look at this
extra revenue and see whether we could
divert some of it into its original
intent which was having less smoking in
new hampshire
and
focusing on
young people
and
finding what are the effective programs
that keep people from smoking i know
there are those who think this that and
the other drug
leads people to
uh addictive drugs but smoking really is
the first gateway
to
other
substance use
and it bothers me terribly in the north
country to
drive around into
populated villages towns cities and see
young people smoking as a former smoker
i know how hard it is
to give it up
and how much damage it does so
do you have anything to do with how the
money is spent
or can encourage
some people who do
to really understand that we have extra
revenue this year that could be directed
to this very important place
thank you for the question i don't have
any ability to
send that money anywhere i provide
estimates when it's provided i can't
speak to uh you know policy questions
about what should happen with that money
and you remember that bill and it just
it was many part of many things so
obviously it's a legislative um
requirement not not the justice
department's requirement but yeah that
that was the year where
so many bills went up uh not being even
having a hearing in the senate and they
just disappeared
i had a few of them at the time i
thought it would probably be the most
important thing i did as a legislator
right i've had bills that disappeared
too we're talking about the life
expectancy of young people here in new
hampshire oh that's fine so maybe you
could follow up on that
oh
yeah
chris
i just wanted to comment that in statute
the first 40 million of the settlement
is deposited in the education trust fund
so the legislature has already
determined what's to happen with the
first 40 million
any balance above 40 million will be
deposited into the general fund and then
it's up to the legislature to determine
how to spend that money and that's done
through the operating budget and through
legislative specials and i think you've
probably seen a number of legislative
specials this session that have
appropriated funds
for certain purposes
hang on representative do you have a
question of chris
well i guess for you and just for maybe
them i think one of the factors you said
that changed the amount of the trust
fund is
is
the lack of a proportionality of usage
across states that are part of the ms
part of the master settlement agreement
so with the change in the mass law and
the flavor tax that
and banning all those flavor driving
everybody new hampshire drive up what
our numbers would look like even though
they're not necessarily new hampshire
residents that would would that change
the percentage and give us more money in
massachusetts isn't that formula set
isn't that why don't you cover that
historically it's been set it doesn't
matter where the smoking occurs now it's
that's my understanding this is a good
question and um it's actually it is set
so every state has a set allocation and
this money we don't actually receive
straight from
the tobacco companies they all deposit
it into an account and then that account
gets distributed and disbursed to the
states based on those set allocated
percentages
right so we
new hampshire residents can stop smoking
massachusetts people can stop buying
cigarettes here we're still going to get
we would get the allocation that is
allocated to us based on percentage if
it changes
if certain laws were to change the total
consumption of cigarettes across the
united states then that could change the
amount that we receive
okay thank you representative had a
question too
well just a comment about the previous
one i believe that the state of new
hampshire gives absolutely nothing to
tobacco prevention
it's possible that there's a very very
small amount in hhs money
on
but this is coming in this year so it
will be part of the surplus next year
when the budget is decided
so someone would have to bring in a bill
directed towards prevention
and a lot of effort is spent on
getting people to give up
smoking and there are products that
people buy and so there's
there are groups that are incentivized
to get people to stop smoking because
they produce those
medications or
processes
but the
the young people part is much more
difficult and it would take a
relationship between the department of
education and health and human services
because these are mostly people of
course who are still in
have not graduated from high school
representative tucker as you know
they they have nothing to do with yeah
did that no that was for the committee
then
yeah thank you yeah okay that's what
i think it's easy different you know
we focus on whether
having certain kinds of charitable
gaming and so forth
results in addiction but this is a
problem that's been on for many years
and we still have it and we do have
income that
can be directed
to solving it so it it seems to me that
we're missing an opportunity and maybe
it's because we hear about the funds in
may
rather than at the beginning of the
legislative season where we're coming up
with bills i don't know
but i hold myself partly accountable for
letting you're not wrong i mean the
original you could say that the original
intent of all this was for the money was
supposed to be used for prevention and
all of that
and treatment and treatment for people
who got illnesses because of smoking and
this predates
you and i being in the legislature maybe
i'm not true representative
right
when three million was put in by a
senator and the next year the senator
wasn't there and they took it out
so i think i just wanted to sort of
encourage the whole committee to be
thinking about this because
there aren't very many problems in the
state
that can be solved by money that is
readily available
directed it you know that's hard to do
so we have affordable housing as a
problem where do we get money
representative murphy no thank you mr
chairman i would just offer a a
a
potential
amendment to your bill coming forward
that you expand the scope of that unused
money
if you look at the social determinants
of health nearly 70 of every healthcare
dollar is spent on
personal choices that
end up in medical treatment so it's not
just smoking it's alcohol use it is
obesity it is drugs it is speeding so
you could actually potentially expand
your bill to include other areas beyond
just um
the um uh the cigarette smoking so
that's a huge nut when you think about
health care in 70 of our health care
dollar is spent on preventative
illnesses in diseases that we
you know based on our um personal
choices so just enough you know a
thought
representative murphy i i actually agree
with you 100 it is it is those
personal habits that create a
good amount of our health care costs
big number representative bursting thank
you mr chair thank you gentlemen for
testifying shortly before
you all came into the room we were
discussing the fda and the
potential ban on methylated cigarettes
and flavored cigars
um i'd love to hear your your comments
on that
if that goes into effect would we see
the msa estimate increase as people
hoard swisher sweets and newports prior
to the band i'd just love to hear your
thoughts
that's also
a good question
i
could submit a memo to update on the
predicted effect of that it could affect
the
eventual payment in several different
ways if people shift to smoking
cigarettes
then it would obviously increase
due to the volume increase
if people
stop smoking so many cigarettes then it
would decrease it
with something like that it's difficult
to predict what
people might how people might uh
smoke you know because with kovid people
could have smoked more they could have
smoked less and
fear of not going out and purchasing
cigarettes so
it's difficult to predict how any
specific policy change might affect
smoking but the underlying question is
how many cigarettes are being sold
how much profit is being made what's
inflation doing
yes sir let me ask you
okay
how about vaping product nicotine vaping
products was that wrapped into the
settlement is that considered part of
the or is just strictly cigarettes do
you know off-topic
vaping products
do not contribute to the ms contribution
okay
but they are
regulated so
one of the things that our office does
is we
collect wholesaler reports
to
determine how many cigarettes are being
sold
and so vaping companies which are
required to
register with the department of revenue
are required to submit
wholesaler reports if they're registered
as a wholesaler with the department of
revenue to us awesome okay
thank you
any other questions
what was it on me
yeah are those reports confidential or
i do know that the
uh msa sales numbers are confidential
i
i'm not sure about the reports i would
have to look that up i i mean
particularly the vaping reports because
we have no way of knowing what's going
on with that market at this point
i can tell you that the only thing that
vaping companies are required to report
on those reports or how many cigarettes
they sell so cigarettes
so
when we receive the reports i i'm not
sure that they would be particularly
informative as to what's happening to
the vaping market
okay
okay i think we're all set
thank you both very much for being here
good seeing you again
if i recognized you
he was he won the marijuana commission
with me
one of them
the 5g commission right right thankfully
i might forget my commissions now which
one right
okay um thank you both and i um
okay committee
oh thank you thanks so much for your
time
and thank you uh
chris thank you chris well
what i want to do now with the committee
is
probably may take
10 minutes it may take 15 minutes so
if you don't mind we want to we want to
talk about we have two
two senate messages that we uh need to
deal with
um i'm just gonna go down the ones
things that we've or um i've dealt with
um
but by the way an update on army the one
million dollars
it was it was attached to a labor bill
which was a mistake the the
the um
the speaker
then senator guida has attached it to a
uh um
a senate bill over there
that
and
it's
it's i think it passed
and it no i guess it was a house bill
because it was a house bill over there
and and it's and it's a
veterans affairs bill
it's a non-german but doesn't matter
over there if it's germaine or not
so
uh i've already i talked to our
representative about baldusero gave a
heads up that you know we want this to
pass so so that's the update on that one
um
and there'll probably be a
committee a conference on that
in veterans affair but i threw my two
cents in with with uh rip bell cesaro
um
the uh
the one
one other note i want to make before i
get into these other things is the um
the commission on worldwide reporting
um
we've
it's going to be
i guess i'm going to chair it norm asked
me to chair it i'm going to chair it rip
center spillsbury and representative
schomburg is going to be on it
whenever we meet
because we're going to bring experts in
um we're still waiting for the other
appointments that we we haven't had in
that bill that we would
have certain experts in on the panel
with us
when we call these meetings we'll make
sure the whole committee knows
uh if you can make it uh you can we we
viewed it as education for the whole
committee what we did in the commission
format so be just keep
keep an eye on your your uh
your emails over the summer period
because we're probably going to get
started hopefully hopefully get started
in june but we'll see
um
we house bill 355 the keynote bill
we had talked about in the committee
uh we asked for a committee at
conference
the conferees are going to be abrami
spills barry genegy and ames i think
they're all aware of this and i do want
to talk to
uh everybody after we're done today to
the
four of us three others and myself to
pick a date it's good for us to talk to
the
uh senate next week
so that one's done
then we had house bill d
624 which was a uh
sec had to do with sex fees
uh it was a
science and tech bill i was just asked
to talk to representatives i looked at
the bill the amendment that was done by
the senate had nothing to do with
revenue fees or anything like that it
was on other stuff
they're going to be asking for a
committee a conference with the senate
but we're not going to be represented in
that
then house bill
uh
winnipeg
winnipesaukee river basin remember that
bill
uh
huh
uh 1339
and we were second committee um
and uh representative ranzil i was the
chair of that committee i talked to him
again there was nothing in that bill
that impacted us in terms of what the
senate did so i said whatever you guys
want to do
and so they're going to concur i'm just
this is just informational at this point
uh house bill 1584 the county fair bill
which is very recent we all remember
uh the senate changed that to
250 000 for the one year
and that that they'd have to come back
and ask every year for the two hundred
and fifty now
what happens when we're second we were
second committee on that
normally the
uh
paul smith the clerk will notify the
chair of the second committee to make
sure you talk to the first he didn't do
that i saw him yesterday i said you know
this one actually had the money part
and but i it turns out i was going to
call
representative pearl anyway
just the bottom line on that is that um
he had reached out to lead
representative led who was the prime
sponsor and uh
and the commissioner jasper
and they're both okay with it so they're
going to concur with that but that's
just as an update for the committee as
to what's happened to some of our bills
um
[Music]
then there's two others and
say again it'll be in the budget or not
the 250 is going to be 50 it won't be
every year no just be it one time
they have to ask every budget exactly
exactly the fund stays i mean the part
of the bill that came to us because of
the fund establish the fund
with the fund is there they're gonna
they're gonna seat it with 250. it's not
going to be 250 a year until we hit the
million remember that part of it
so
now
the um
i think you give me a heads up on this
uh ribs around me and uh that
tomorrow
there's some senate bill senate bill 313
and senate bill 316.
uh one was well the first 13 was the
professor these are all recent
professional office fees bill that
representative amy put a basically an
administrative
cleaning on it
low probability that
that they could ask for a committee on
conference because we amended their bill
they could but we'll have to act on the
floor
we'll uh in terms of appointing if they
ask for a committee
on the floor tomorrow i will or thursday
i'll
i'll pick up
you'll probably be on that one right
because we're 17 nothing
yeah it was executive departments
and exactly
it's basically there oh it is theirs
right it is there so we wouldn't we
wouldn't be involved in that although i
would i would talk to uh the
representative the chair of that
committee
but and then 316 the lucky seven bill
where i i put that full our amendment on
i don't i can't foresee them uh asking
for a committee on that but they they
could so i'm just
throwing that out
um
okay so the two that we have to really
talk about are house bill 1221
which was the rates of
of
business profit tax and that was the
bill it was a bit of a partisan bill
partisan bill um
okay 7.6
to 7.5 i was trying to be nice about it
so
um you have
is they have the uh side by side here
what they did is if you just read the
the bowl didn't show out in the in the
uh but in that first section on the
senate version
this bill also provides for a one-time
payment by the state of an amount equal
to 7.5 percent of required political
subdivision employer contributions made
to the state retirement system for group
one teachers
and all group two members
so
my understanding was that
the the 7.5
passed the house
and and it made it over to
the senate
and the in the ways
whatever committee i'm assuming ways of
means killed it but then there was a
floor amendment to add to 7.5 one time
next year
okay
and i think par someone told me it was
in honor of renny yes it was his bill it
was his bill so that they decided to do
that which was fine
so i i said well and then the only
question i had was
how much money are we talking about here
and it turns out it's around 28 million
i've been in conversation with
representative um
almi
about this
and then and then she said well is that
an
is that an
actuarial number
and it turns out we've changed the way
we do this it used to be
um and you can weigh in my friend in the
back there chris we used to
we used to
we would ask the actuaries a lot of
times you know can you do this at bill's
gonna what was the impact and they
wouldn't charge us and then at one point
they said wait a minute
wait a minute this is a lot of work
we're going to charge you we're going to
charge the state
every time we did one of these before
the bill actually became
you know passed
so
uh
so they did not do
an actuarial number on this just fyi i
mean it's going to be in the ballpark i
mean it wasn't like they didn't pull the
number out of the air the people who
know
kind of estimated probably be a couple
million either way which in the grand
scheme of things is nothing
so i have no problem with this but i
said to myself you know 28 million maybe
i should talk to the speaker
so i talked to the speaker um i actually
brought chris up with me at one point
because he was confused between this one
and another there was another pension
one that was like 42 million
we he's all straightened out now and i
said okay chief men call him chief but
you know how uh you know
what
you know what you're with your guys
because i i said i'm willing to concur
depending on the committee but
uh on this
and he said well i'll let you know
tomorrow meaning today so
i don't know but
so
i just want the it's a one-time thing
obviously
we we'd like to see the bill saved
because we want to see that's 7.6 go to
7.5
at the very least
uh what i'll say to the speaker if he
says no i'm going to pull the
here's the
if if if the speaker says no problem
with the 40 or the 28
million because let me tell you he
pulled out a spreadsheet just understand
and the reason i purposely asked him
because i know there's a lot of ass
right now a lot of ass and he had a
spreadsheet as to there's only so much
that can be spent
and so i was just making sure that that
was on his list
but you know this 28 without us saying
you know let's do this so
so
um
i
i just want to get the sense i mean is
everybody okay with with the 28 million
being added
depends on things you know patrick i
don't have a problem with the 28 million
being that i have a problem with it just
being a one-year
one-year retirement contribution
how can how can
towns
go next year when they set their budgets
if they don't know if they're going to
get
another
i i understand where you're coming from
i i i just this is an irish
i understand a totally non-germane
amendment attached to our bill here so i
don't know you know i uh representative
tucker you had your hand up no i was
okay
yeah because we could talk all day about
this uh you know we're gonna have all
day representative pillsbury
thank you mr chairman um yeah i mean i
only saw this on sunday evening um but
just reading the preferatory language
there's a whole bunch of legislative
findings
i take it as
an intent that it would represent a
one-time
curtailment of the real property tax so
that it wouldn't affect the calculations
that go into the spending side of the
munici budget and having been on a town
finance committee that's the way i would
so some of the hands online
thank you mr chair so
i had a conversation said on the guide
over and weighs the means in the senate
and a lot of this was around the concern
of ongoing expenses in an unknown
economy
um and the fact that we don't know we're
gonna have 28 million dollars with
everything else that's going on right
now down the road but we do know we have
it right now and so let's do what we can
for the best purposes of the towns and
cities which give give them the 7.5
reevaluate and then decide whether we
can continue this on and i i think again
it's one time money is this
appropriation this was a swap from the
28 million dollars that we already
associated the bill that we sent over
so it was already earmarked
but the one we sent over was year marked
year after year after year after year
this one is just we know we have uh
funds now let's give it to the towns
help them out and we'll see what's going
on you know we heard we're talking about
recessions earlier today with dra so
nobody knows what's going on and putting
an uncertainty of a guarantee year over
year versus let's give them what we know
we can guarantee right now and then
figure out where to move on from there
okay any other hands of yeah oh okay
thank you the language says seven and a
half percent of both the normal and
accrued liability contributions
the normal i'm comfortable with the
accrued liability contributions can you
explain that to me a little bit i i wish
i knew again this is not our thing i
mean i i don't know chris do you have
i'm not sure i have a lot to offer but i
think the intent is to
just make it clear that it's the entire
employer contribution amount
that includes group two and group one
teachers that would be seven point five
percent of that as i'm
as many people are aware the the
employer contribution is broken into the
current year amount that you pay plus
the unfunded liability aspect or the
under the accrued liability aspect
and that's where you get your percent
that they have to pay is a portion of
retirement so i think that the language
just is to be clear that it's the whole
number not just the current year amount
which is a lesser number so like
i'm just going to use a an example
you know if your employer contribution
is 30
of that amount
maybe 25 is taking care of the unfunded
liability aspect and 5 is what's your
current liability so they're just saying
let's make sure we take care of
or include the full amount when we do
this calculation let's say let's do
seven and a half percent
but
i would be happily be corrected by
somebody with more knowledge in myself
it just as
i fear that it could be
read as seven and a half percent of the
accrued liability meaning not just the
current portion of that liability but
the whole enchilada which would be
ridiculous i don't think they make that
kind of mistake
if
right so if you recall the um bill that
the house passed um that started in 24
so it was a seven and a half it's the
same basically essentially the same idea
what you have in front of you now
the cost of that in terms of the fiscal
note was just around 28 million dollars
the same language was there around the
accrued liability and and um
current
so i again i believe the intent is to
make it clear to the retirement system
that when they set their rates it's
based on this accrued liability as well
as your current liability that that's
the number they percent they want to be
using when they calculate this 7.5
percent towards the community's
revenue sharing or contribution
but i don't believe it would be
to your concern i don't think they're
going to take the
five billion dollars of unfunded
liability and say
we're going to use that as the base
number and figure out what we need in
one year to give out to the communities
it's it's smoothed out over a period of
time i didn't mean to be pedantic i just
wanted to be cautious
this is the house position
this is the house position because it
passed the house as a multi-year
commitment a permanent commitment
and um
the senate took i believe exactly the
same language i think they did i heard
and
and took
uh took it down to a single year
on it's supposed to be paid out in the
22 23 budget
as of the first it becomes effective
july 1 of this year
but that at least gives the towns
i think all the towns will have done
their
budget
for
4 22
22 no 23
huh
and we do them in march and some places
or i guess i guess some of the cities do
them in november
yeah
yeah calendar year right
um
i guess ours has gone through a year too
i can't remember
but at least that means that they've got
six months to
know that they have that money for one
year and what are they going to do with
it
but
well you know
i do really plan on a big debate on this
because
it's going to happen or it's not
what
yes
oh right right that's the but one of the
things they could come up with was not
so all right
okay um
so
yeah yeah
okay
right
yes
except for when it comes up that the
next year you have to add that back in
and people see their taxes going up when
they wouldn't have
and they actually call out the property
tax relief act of 2022.
yeah so what happens at the
at the uh
the house position that we voted on just
this past week where we reinforce
the idea that will be
multi-year
we didn't vote on that last week did we
i thought it was there didn't
yeah
it was
before that it was it went to the senate
and the senate considered it they
considered it they killed it in the
committee yeah it was on the floor that
senator bradley
somewhere behind back room somewhere
there was discussion and they decided to
re-resurrect it
using the same language but for one year
yeah and it was on the floor of the
senate that this was
was passed and i think that they
they either
that's what i thought
representative o'brien was up last week
and made a
a presentation on this that we voted on
i i that we put it onto a senate bill ah
grips of a bromine may yeah interject
yes um so the house bill that went over
to the senate um they they essentially
it killed that either take table their
itled it and then their
proposal back to the house is what
you're debating right now
last week the house
reaffirmed its position
and attached a floor amendment to house
assuming senate bill 333
which basically um would
provide the 7.5 starting in uh 2024 it
would happen every year thereafter
basically the house position that was in
your house bill that went over
um so so
there is a
senate bill that has the that position
on it
um i don't know what the status of that
might be at this time but but for them
for them to take
this though and add it to this attach it
to one of our bills
because it was convenient they just
found a bill to attach it to doesn't
matter if it's jermaine or not so that's
what they did
right
so do you remember which committee is in
charge of 333 if it comes back from the
senate
yeah e-dna correct
um
but again we we haven't i don't believe
anybody's heard what the the senate
intends on doing if they're gonna
concur non-concurrent and non-concurrent
or request a recovery conference right
um they essentially could say that we've
provided you our position
in um house bill 1221
um and that we don't
want to do anything with this bill but
if they
like
333 the way they had it
on
and decide to ask for a committee of
conference
then
the committee
that sent the bill is the one that has
to respond
at the end of the day
tomorrow when the senate sends over
this could be one of the ones that comes
back to us
we don't know we don't know that yet
we don't know question yes
is the uh
senate bill 333
attachment
uh for the same
you said fiscal year 24
moving forward
there's this bill fiscal year 23 that
we're talking about right now
so so what you have before you is the
senate's position
on providing a municipal contribution
for one year they didn't agree with
providing it um year after year is
fiscal year 23. and and there um the
senate's position was to provide that in
23 so that it could be used to that so
so then the other bill is for a period
of time it starts in fiscal year 24.
that's correct so they're really not in
conflict with other this this bill
yeah i think i think we've okay
we all concur
uh but stay tuned i will we'll see what
happens with the speaker in terms of and
i'll let everybody know
all right let's let's move on to the
next let's move on to the next bill real
quick uh we had an uh preliminary
conversation
about uh house bill 1097
and that was relative to the taxation of
income of new hampshire residents when
working remotely
for an out-of-state employee or employer
and
the senate modified the language and
there's a side-by-side on that
um
it's
this one
and the key thing is the language in
that first block there and uh i think
representative spillsbury you you you
addressed that
the last time we met
uh representative ames i think he said
he needed more time to think about it
um but they also
they took out the
let me ask representative supposedly
they took out
uh
uh i can give you a very quick
they took those out the changes are
in the
a caption 78 f1
where we had purpose they've added
declaration
and that goes to comments that uh
representative almi had made i believe
about uh
whether purpose was sufficient enough to
state that we're actually changing our
position
anyway um
income
in the fourth line from employer
employee relationships such as wage
income salary income or other employee
compensation
and they changed
earned and received to earned or
received
and they changed in the second to last
line
may to shout
and i think they were very responsive to
the suggestions that were made to them i
i'm pleased with the uh language i think
it very much improves what we have done
and so i recommend it right
by the way
did the gray highlighting when we make
copies goes away that's a problem
um like we have to use some something
else to do when we make
xerox because it's gray highlight also
indicates and
and the original i don't know what i did
with the original but the original was i
could
clearly see the uh
the gray lines but
but how about uh 78 f
2 and
is that you okay with that being
eliminated
okay
so
yes
they're deleted
because they simply are surplusage
by
making uh
the description of what tax we are
talking about more clear in lines
uh four and five
then it becomes completely unnecessary
to distinguish this tax from the
business tax okay good
um
janaegan has handed first representative
negan and i mean then i forget to
dictate
the same question
so i know when we
brought this
fourth in the house we um
got buy-in from the attorney general and
dra
representative spielsberg do we know if
dra and the attorney general have bought
into this new language
and the answer is yes um
keane was here earlier i was going to
point to him now but
he's the one who specifically
fashioned these words in response to the
request from the senate committee
and he ran them by me before taking them
back to the senate and i think they're
excellent
okay with some army then i guess just to
make sure this he also agreed with
taking out the second and third sections
representative
yeah i think it's fine what's been
proposed on the senate side um
and i think the uh business private tax
sections that they took out
are appropriately taken out uh they
created confusion in my mind anyway and
set us up for a uh sort of
counter-attack if you will by
states that might be subject to this
that we were being uh
two-sided about this that uh
we had one standard for ourselves and
another standard for the other guys um
so that that wasn't a good posture i
think it's it's uh
more more carefully tailored now it's a
simple statement of uh
of the seven interests of the state of
new hampshire that relates to personal
income taxation and employer employee
relationship
i think that's uh that's fine i don't
know whether it's gonna going to
in the end prove helpful for anything
but
i see no harm and
potential benefits
okay
so
without objection i i'm gonna recommend
concur okay okay we'll do that
can i ask
the committee wants to concur with 1221
if the speaker comes back to you today
and says
we shouldn't
that's why i said we didn't really
definitively i didn't do what i just did
then i said this
i will uh certainly relate to him that
we're concur
again it's it's 28 million
he had the master
he had the big picture
we don't have the big picture of of all
the money that wants to be spent uh what
if he says i doubt it's a little
probability he's gonna say
no okay so
we'll just have to deal with it now i'll
obviously get a note out to everybody
who is
i'm going to go actually at lunchtime
here now i'm going to run over and i'll
probably have more news
let's continue discussion this afternoon
i will do what i can do
but i'm going to go over now catch him
there's a chair vice chairman that
starts at one i know i could catch him
in the hallway before
but i'm going to go over there now and
and talk to him
okay mr chair i just had a follow-up
question about the hb 1097
yes the
uh statement that representative
spillsbury just made was that the dra
has okayed the language changes and that
sounds great but i was just wondering if
the ag's office actually weighed in
it's my understanding from my
conversation with king wong
that he did specifically run this by the
a.g but i don't have first-hand
knowledge of that i believe that's
correct he went like when he was here
we again this second time we're talking
about this
change
keane was here for that first and i
think he did say that
that he passed it by the ag my
recollection
i mean i think if the intent was that
you know this is the ag's recommendation
to put us in the strongest position to
potentially litigate this issue in the
future
and now we're changing the language from
what they had previously okay that we
yeah i i can't specifically rebut your
comment um
but i would suggest that the ag
liked what we did in the first instance
the ag
did not take part in requesting the
addition of the two
additional provisions relating to
business profits tax and business
enterprise tax
so this
if anything strengthens what they had
already agreed to
i am i i can't imagine that if we ask
them that they wouldn't
um approve of it so that's just
speculation but i think pretty confident
speculation
well we'll see if we can track them down
today but
you know it's hit and miss if the the
right people are there
um
but i think we hit because
we're a depression out of to
today they want they want to know the
clerk paul smith wants to know
what um what our positions are on these
so
it's creating i hope it's finance
it's creating the the list that the
speaker is looking at of what we can
afford
here's this big master list because it
isn't us it says
opera money has
uh
infrastructure money federal and then he
has state surplus money three
it's a big spreadsheet that he's got
okay so
that's what he's working off of and i'm
sure he's in in in conversation with
representative grumberger
about that
all right
all right well we gotta we we're we're
gonna have uh about you know 38 minutes
let's we can we can we have guests
okay okay why don't we why don't we get
started um
we have uh amy
johan
the chief tax officer
and i think the commissioner
good afternoon chris nicolopoulos the
commissioner of insurance right thank
you and amy i'm amy ducam thanks for
having me today so this is just like a
mid-course just update on what you're
seeing and
understanding there was a handout that
they provided that was in the packet
that we had earlier
so
floor is yours
okay so
y'all got your hand out i'll go through
it with you
and today's um purpose we're going to
touch on and review our revenue sources
and why they're coming in at
approximately 26 million over the plan
well we won't complain about that too
much no no complaints here
so
the majority of our revenue is from our
licensed companies
and our risk retention groups what we
call the admitted market
and the property and casualty lines of
business are taxed at 1.25 percent
whereas the accident health lines are
taxed at two percent
so we collect tax returns from
approximately 1200 insurance companies
that are due on or before march 15th of
each year
in accordance with our statutes the
companies will pay the premium taxes
that are due for the calendar year 2021
and then we subtract out the estimated
payment that they paid on their prior
year's tax return
and then we collect an extra estimated
prepayment tax for the calendar year
2022.
so if we look at the next page you'll
see here that i've laid out
what we've submitted for projections
based on our tax base our tax credits
and fee data
so for fiscal year 22
we have 130 million and fiscal year 2023
we projected 135
million excuse me
so on the next page we're gonna dive a
little deeper and go into
what those numbers actually mean
so on the left hand column you'll see
the 130 million
that we had projected and next to that
is what we expect fiscal year end to
look like as of june 30th
we are expecting a bottom line of
156.8 million
so if we start with our our top line
here we'll go through our calculation
which is our premium tax liability for
the calendar year 2021
we will have expected to collect
126.2 million
and then we take away the prepayment
that is applied from their previous
year's
tax return which was 117 mil
117.5 million
and then on the third line you'll see
the prepayment for the following year so
this is their estimated tax that they're
paying upfront for calendar year 2022
and you'll see that line is always going
to be the same as the top line because
they're paying 100 percent of their
then we are expecting to collect 5.9
million premium tax from the
non-admitted market
which brings our total projected fiscal
year in revenue to
140.8 million dollars
our licenses fees and penalties we
expect to be about 26.2 million
these are
you know rather high
compared to what we've seen in the past
we feel with the pandemic and more
people working remotely
that they were more apt to get licensed
across different states on the other
hand a lot of them may have let their
licenses lap so when they went to renew
they were paying at twice the cost
because their license had lapsed
and these all these producers producers
and adjusters are paying on a two-year
term so we wouldn't expect to see
quite as high numbers next year
we also had a one-time unprecedented
collection of administrative fees where
we collected an additional
500 000 from the appointment of
producers
and then we collected penalties by our
enforcement division and these vary
greatly every year very hard to predict
uh 2021 we collected almost a half a
million dollars
whereas in 2020 we only collected 85 000
so due to the nature of the enforcement
division it's hard to predict what type
on the next page it's
informational
purposes of our premium tax base which
is based on premium written
the companies wrote over seven billion
dollars worth of in premium in new
hampshire and you'll see from the pie
chart that that's split fairly equally
between the property and casualty lines
and the health lines at about forty
percent
uh however you know more of the tax is
collected on the health side like i
mentioned they are taxed at a higher
so on the next page currently we have
any idea how many how many uh
products
or companies or products that are being
taxed i mean is it
yeah 1200 companies okay that are
submitting that's amazing okay that's
that's what i'm getting at okay thank
you thank you yeah
so as of april 30th our favorable
variance was 26.2 million
18 million of that in premium tax and
8.2 million of that in fee revenue
and uh like men like i mentioned you
know the
increase is primarily due to a
significant increase in the tax base
which is those premiums written
um
which increased eight percent from prior
year calendar year 2020.
other factors we have impacting the
growth in premiums are primarily the
pandemic and how it's lasted longer than
we expected
and the impacts the economic impacts
that it's made for both the labor and
the housing market which eventually
affect the insurance market
yes representative
yeah on
how much of that taxable premiums was
due to more premiums versus premiums
being more expensive
all the the rates versus
the rate increases um i don't have an
exact figure for that
i don't think we have an ability to to
discern what is increasing premium uh
premiums on existing business and on new
business
i think we we can anecdotally we know
that
um
more life insurance policies have been
written
uh the the increase we've seen isn't
premium increase it's people who during
the pandemic thought maybe i should get
life insurance
um i think likewise we've seen an
increase in health uh health premium
that is not consistent with rate
increase is consistent with uh
more uh more covered lives
um and i think also that is that is
partly driven because of the economy
strength of the economy and partly
driven because during a pandemic people
okay
so
as we've mentioned the favorable
variance in fees is attributable to the
producer and adjuster licensing fees
which we don't feel will stay at the
same levels
what we'll see for the months of may and
june the revenue growth will slow down
as
at this time we are processing refunds
for overpayments on the tax returns
and um when we take a look at what
fiscal year end will look like
we are projecting like i said the 26.8
million and that's on a cash basis
so the final results that will be
reported in the annual comprehensive
financial report are on a modified
accrual basis so those we expect to see
the next
page is
simply five-year historic
information of our actual results
reported in the annual comprehensive
financial report
versus what we had planned and you'll
see those do fluctuate year after year
where some years they're up some years
it's not really a question it's just for
the ones who weren't here through all of
this in the past
on
the change in the revenues
is doubled
in years where the revenues go up and
half
when they go down
so on
when when they go up one year they
because
this year's
tax
at the beginning of next
next year that is the next day
uh
and then next year
if their revenues are lower
they are
getting back
tax
that they'd overpaid
which is what you're going to be dealing
with soon
correct
so it's it's very disconcerting
and it happened because the senate
wanted to cut
the casualty in property taxes
and they didn't want to have to pay for
the tail and so they required that we
pay only once a year instead of four
times a year so we have no information
until april
on the next slide
i want to take a look at the april april
results as they have
they are four million dollars below plan
and that's due to our transfer
that we made to the grant advantage
health care trust fund
having a negative is
typical
for april because of this transfer that
we make every year
so we are collecting premium tax from
the three managed care organizations
that have contracted with the hhs to
place business in the granite advantage
health care fund
and then we need to transfer that
revenue to dhhs by april 15th so you'll
see a decrease every april
it's important to note that if more
taxes collected for the program
then more taxes transferred for the
program so
um therefore it has a net zero impact on
our projections
um we did projects
again yeah this one is is a question do
you remember when this expires because
it was time limited
this deal that was made by the senate
again
i think there's one more year on the
um so we had anticipated the transfer to
be 8.6 million
premiums came in higher than we were
expecting so we did end up transferring
10.2 million which resulted in a 1.6
million variance
and then the remaining variance there is
comprised of the refunds on the
overpayments that we've started and
timing of collections of taxes from the
non-market
and the fees and that's
do you have more questions
well it's
positive outlook represent me do you
that's a tough one we spent a lot of
time with our team
uh i think some things happened in last
year that we didn't anticipate we didn't
anticipate that life premiums would go
up ten percent
that the health premiums would go up as
much as they did six percent
um i think that's going to moderate some
we think that's going to moderate some
and as representative almighty pointed
out when you when a line moderates we
experienced a double reduction
so not only
would we anticipate half of the increase
in premium new premium that we saw this
year going away if everything stayed the
same any reduction gets experienced
double down
um and so because of that i think
the 135 million uh that we've we have
planned is is appropriate for a safe
estimate um
could it be 140 million yeah i think
that but i think those numbers
uh are as good as we can guess
because we don't know
if people are going to stay with those
life products that they purchased while
they were worried in the pandemic
we're seeing unemployment numbers that
are shockingly low
[Music]
each year
we see premium for our workers comp
stagnate it's about 200 million a year
year after year even as
even as uh
pay average pay in new hampshire goes up
even as unemployment goes down and
that's big it's offset because we have a
very safe workforce here in new
hampshire um i think there'll be some
increase in
in pnc lines because of inflation
but that may be offset by actual
projections of
of investment income which will be
shocking for insurance companies to
start planning for investment income
again
i know that's a lot of words to not say
a whole lot but
i feel confident in the 135 that we've
any other question so
the uh
the granite advantage healthcare fund
trust fund
is the last thing in that handout we've
got so in terms of where the statute
um so
any other questions
i'm going saying none
well thank you before you leave uh
commissioner there's one familiar face
in the audience here that we hear is
retiring
um
we'd like to
can you just
go out later come on uh actually norma
has retired norma stalin's uh retired
this summer but we convinced her to come
back part-time through our tax season
this year right so she's been spending
time uh transitioning our tax team of
thank you
uh it's been a pleasure you know serving
and reporting
to the committee
over the last 12 years
i
in some respects will miss it but in
other respects you know it's time it was
time for me to move on but i thank you
all
well i just want to say that you've done
a great job over the years and uh you
know explaining this to us and uh you
know so every time we explain it then a
year later we have to ask similar
questions but you know
so we just want to give you a round of
applause thank you thank you
have a great have a great retirement
[Applause]
well
we have a gap
of uh
oh a long gap
okay oh yeah i'm uh you know well it's
not going to take 40 minutes
i can probably
thank you guys
so i did speak to the speaker
he was having a meeting with he's going
to go and have a meeting with bradley it
was already scheduled
and he's going to talk to bradley about
it as to where it ended
so i know he's upstairs in 301 right now
representative lange he's since he's
chair of whatever he's chair of
agriculture or whatever
fishing game
um
that i told them to tap on the shoulder
on the way and
to get it but we have
unfortunately is there any way we can
[Music]
so
yeah i don't know why this is an issue
but
it shouldn't be i think we're still okay
but i'll leave it down but um
and i have a message in the king on the
other
thing
so
oh no no don't ask the update
you know i want to why don't we recess
for
maybe come back at 10-2
usually they show up a little early
we could probably start a little early
i guess the finance leaders are probably
in that meeting too so yeah
yeah i'm going to go up there now yeah
okay
oh
so the senate passed
let me give a quick norm update uh i
talked to him i tried to i didn't call
him this weekend you did yeah i talked
to him on the way home last night his
biggest problem now is his ankle
he can't put any weight on his ankle now
and now i think he tore some ligaments
when he fell
way back you know in easter well that
and some infection in his lungs yeah but
uh he had it yeah i know it was a
pulmonary doctor came in that right
before i talked to him he said the
doctor came in and said it's that's
clearing up a little bit yeah so that
was good news
so but you probably won't see him for a
few weeks
probably
yeah he's alternating between a
but he's still he's still at the
whittier rehab
um he'll probably be discharged he said
he had an appointment with a surgeon
uh next week now
it's torn ligaments the surgeons did
they reattach things what
usually not just let it heal right
right right yeah i'm not quite sure why
he's going to see a surgeon that night
but maybe just a referral from later i
don't know
well the day before he thought it was
just healed so it was
i thought he said ankle
but
whatever
it's down there
yeah all right so well he shouldn't go
home until he can
well i'm sure they take some care of
himself because
brenda i don't know if she can cope with
well the pt's been uh you know they've
been up and down steps they've been
getting them in and out of a mock-up car
in the treatment area getting in and out
of a car
so
you know they're working on
but
well let me run upstairs and i will
hopefully have a report let's get we
convene a 10-2 co looking maybe here a
little early sometimes they do show up
early we can start early
ugh
in early june
so
three new stores three new exciting
opportunities to make additional funds
so uh obviously tina's here she works
with the numbers every day and she'll
bring you through
the numbers that were sent over
thank you
good afternoon chair members of
committee for the record my name is tina
demers cfo of the liquor commission
before i walk you through the report
that we provided i first wanted to
explain where we are year to date
uh the revenue numbers on the revenue
focus show that we're actually under
planned by 4.1 million or 3.7 percent
which is not the case because
the 108 million and the year-to-date
transfer includes the transfers to hhs
to date
our plan number only includes the 10.4
million per the section 176 16 which is
the five percent of the previous fiscal
year's gross profit
the plan does not include the additional
8.7 million that's been transferred
pursuant to rsa 126 a aaa3
because that's calculated quarterly
during the fiscal year based on the
granted advantage healthcare trust fund
needs for
non-federal funding
so therefore the revenue compared to
plan is actually 116
million an increase of 4.6 million or
4.1 percent um
then you deduct the 8.7 million and that
leaves the 108 million that's
transferred to the general fund
so we've actually laid out our
presentation in the same manner
so if you look at fy22
line one which is the net revenue
the original plan we had at 148
we're now projecting
153.7 million and if you deduct the 10.4
million which is the 5 of our profits to
hhs that has a revised plan of 143.3
compared to uh the current plan which is
137.6
so we have um a increase of or over plan
of 5.7 million and if you look at fy23
we have the same comparable increase of
about 5.4 million we're projecting
so
on line six
is that additional funds that are being
transferred or that have been
transferred to hhs the 8.7 million and
that would have the transfer to the
general fund at
134.6 million
and then we have beer tax which is stays
pretty consistent at about 13.2 million
for a total general fund transfer of
147.8 million and then
and then at the bottom we did provide
and i'd be happy to take any question
in terms of the transfers uh
chris provided us a sheet
that showed that in july there was from
doing this right it was a
transfer 10 million and nothing in
august september october then 3.1 in
november 3.4 in december nothing in
january
then 2.5
is it how come it's not kind of spread
evenly or
so the 10 million is the the initial 5
of the prior year's profit that is
transferred and then the rest of it is
based on hhs's need for the artist right
yeah so they do a quarterly assessment
for the next six months
and then address or request the
additional funds and the timing that
they'll need it to make sure that they
yes this is need to pay for medicaid
right
medicaid
enhancement
yes you
can uh
henry lopez for the record henry
medicaid director this is for the um
granite advantage healthcare program the
yeah um
expansion population
of which today there's about 88 000
enrolls before the public health
emergency federal it was 52 000 and that
we'll talk about now
wait a minute yep thank you thank you
sorry
okay uh could i also ask yes on
your
i think bonding
the
new stores
as you build them
we we don't bond the new stores that
were open uh we do it as a partnership
with our landlords and we lease those
locations
okay
that's all done through additional
square footage in the first 10 years of
the lease and then it drops off at the
so
you attribute the the fact that we're
because we're opening new stores but any
other
i mean maybe you said i was still
thinking about the other thing when you
first talked
so
what other factors do you think are
there um
is
i mean kovitz kind of i know during the
covert period we did a trade-off between
what was sold in restaurants versus what
was
people buying at home
buying in your stores
is that is that leveled up i've seen the
switch well actually restaurants are up
just under 40 percent at this point
about 38.4
so we've seen a nice increase for those
business partners people are clearly uh
going out and spending their money and
uh you know the only area of the
business that seems to be uh
that seems to be lagging a little bit as
our off-premise sale so the grocery the
grocery sales are down about three
percent three and a half percent
at this point so
people aren't uh necessarily buying
their spirits at the grocery stores
where they did during covet for that
convenience they were up 13 14 where the
restaurants were down
at some point at one point 60 percent
but with the restaurants coming back 40
which is great for them and our stores
are strong as you can see we're above
plan above what we projected i'm just
thinking out loud here and it's
dangerous uh that
you know could it be that when the price
of a hamburger goes up
fifty percent
then when it comes to the they get to
the wine aisle they go
i don't think so
well i think there could be a little bit
of that going on i think there could be
i think the costs of everything have uh
have caused people to adjust their
buying patterns how about how about the
cost of your products your spirits and
your wines
the
the wholesalers
looking for you know is it costing you
water procure and then this or therefore
passing it along to customers those are
done quarterly the price increases are
done quarterly in this past quarter
there was some large increases
you know what we're seeing is what
they're saying is the transportation
costs have risen exponentially products
are sitting in the ports in other
countries on ships they're sitting when
they get here and time is money with
with those products i mean
you know everything's got a vintage on
it there's another vintage behind it
there's one in front of it at the store
so when those when those kind of pileups
happen you can uh
you know
the cost of doing business just becomes
exorbitant
glass is a is a big piece of it as well
but transportation again glass glass the
cost of glass and for for
a while during covet especially toward
the end we were seeing a lot of our
business partners
bottle in plastic especially
larger companies jim beam bacardi
smirnoff they were bottling in plastic
because they just couldn't get the glass
that's the first i heard about that
class seeing a problem
maybe formally yes but
now now we're getting down to the now
okay
okay representative murphy then
well thank you just a relatively simple
question i guess is
i was listening to talk about you know
the stores being down to grocery stores
but then the restaurants are up
per bottle of alcohol whatever it might
be
is the revenue to the state the same
whether it's sold in a grocery store
uh one of your stores restaurants you
know that they purchase is it the same
revenue that comes into the state
regardless of where it's sold uh no
because there are our costs to those uh
the people who purchase it varies
depending on uh we do a lot we do a
whole separate
uh quota of deals for grocery stores
that aren't necessarily passed along to
restaurants and then we do
restaurants get a discount depending on
how they buy and where they if they buy
from the warehouse they get a 10
discount and a lot of restaurants
you know especially the smaller
independents take advantage of the sales
in our stores so uh they're they're
allowed to be able to come in and buy at
those prices so
and just to follow up they're very i'm
not trying to be facetious at all but
do you see a huge increase in the number
of spin top bottles being sold versus
cork bottles
and the reason i ask that some people
have complained to me and say not
because of where i'm sitting now but
they say i can't get this open anymore
the cork in the bottle or something like
that have you seen an increase in those
sales the stealth enclosure is is the
twist off bottle and that's clearly
increased
and uh consumers like them and a lot of
the wines are going to them the finer
wines tend not to
to go that way but they're a bit snobby
yeah well
a lot of
[Laughter]
but a lot of companies are moving over
to that thank you
um
well total wine is open another store in
massachusetts uh i think this is this
will be their their seventh and uh but
what they have clearly done is they've
risen they've driven their prices up in
massachusetts which
allowed everybody else to go along with
it so we have
we have seen
their prices increase
between 12 and 14 percent over the last
24 months i think they took advantage of
uh
of the the covet situation knowing that
people were at home and they're kind of
the big retailer there we've we've had
some price increases but we've tried to
to keep our advantage
and we advertise in the in the globe
usually once a month or twice a month to
show those advantages we're still
between two and twelve dollars on
average and on some higher priced items
we can be 30 or 40 dollars cheaper than
total
so
it is it's it's interesting to see what
they've done massachusetts has taken
several price increases which uh which
has clearly helped our business and i
think we'll help it into the future as
well
and these new stores
you know the
the model works people are buying and
you know the new store and range that's
all business from mass and we're trying
to stay as close to the borders and the
highways as we can
we recognize that that's where
a lot of our business comes from can you
tell from
the credit cards or how do you tell that
this mess was it someone periodically
look in the parking lot and see all the
mess plates uh we do surveys in the
store we usually do exit surveys in the
store to see
where where people are coming from our
advertising company our marketing and pr
company does that
now
i think representative romney had her
hand up first and represented murphy
yeah i'd just say that they usually ask
for the zip code
they did it the last time
uh
but i'm wondering
a large part of the lower part of the
market especially has been domestic
in the wine sectors
and
on most of that is coming from places
that are ravaged by drought and fire and
i'm do you have any idea how the
how the california
oregon
market
on
production is going are they disappear
going to disappear on us or
no i think a lot of the smaller wineries
that have been family owned for a number
of years have sold to larger
conglomerates uh the smoke tank is is
is what you're speaking about especially
last year a lot of wines
didn't bottle last year a lot of
companies didn't bottle so you won't see
vintages on finer wines from from those
wineries and some wineries bottled and
are now having to have those products
returned because the the smoke tank is
clearly in the wines
luckily at this point we haven't had no
consumer complaints about that
but it's clearly something that that has
happened
richard murphy thank you um i was just
reflecting on when i was traveling prior
to covid down in the carolinas or in
some of the southern states and they
have the dr i'm thinking about the
covid experience and what may actually
help sales is they have the
drive-throughs as you're probably well
aware of where you call in and you open
up the trunk and they just dump it in
you keep going and so there's actually
no exposure and i was just wondering
have we ever thought of that in the
state for drive-through is there a
reason we couldn't do something like
that how we do that we we have 25 of our
stores have curbside pickup curbside
curbside pickup is what we call it so
you can go online
uh order your product
it it goes into the store you pick your
store that you want
to have it done in i believe it's 25 it
may be 26 stores where we do it now and
all the new stores that we're opening
automatically do it so you can just pick
up pull up to the curb there's
designated spaces one through six
depending on the store you you let the
you call the store at that point you let
them know you're out there they come out
and drop your product in the trunk
yeah yeah
representative murphy don't get out
um
rivers representative genegan
thank you mr chairman um so i think you
mentioned that one of the stores is
moving in range to another location so
does that mean it's a net add of two
stores to the total it will be yes
okay so the the ring stores uh you know
we're just trying to get rid of some of
these older uh
less convenient locations that don't
have enough skus quite frankly it's the
main reason why the selection isn't
there total wine averages 18 to 26 000
square feet
eight years we've we've
closed 12 stores but we've actually
added just under 300 000 square feet of
store
of sales floor so nice you know when we
try to try to make the stores a little
bit bigger a little bit more welcoming
and a little more convenient
going back to the supply chain
i know my daughter works for a company
that was having a problem getting those
products from china
there was a shortage of containers
and the price per container rental was
like unbelievable
i think it's come down now i mean was
that did you face some of that with your
product coming from overseas our
suppliers certainly do yeah the cost of
containers is has
in some cases doubled
and uh
you know there
i think the companies that sell uh
in general especially wine and spirits
are working on thinner margins the
suppliers are right because you you
can't pass along these
exorbitant increases to the consumers
because
your your products will suffer
people
they have a price range where they'll
spend for x
and uh suppliers understand that so i
think that their their profits have
suffered
we expect price increases to happen and
they do but i really think that the
suppliers have restrained themselves in
in
so any other questions from anybody
it doesn't look that way thank you very
much thank you as always thanks for
coming in thank you appreciate it good
to see you we'll see you in uh hopefully
in january thank you
we do well
okay
next we have
we're going to hear from
hhs um
and henry lippin was we just heard from
and
right right thank you
is it amy amy
and there's a handout
okay this this this goes to the well you
start on the wall sure thank you again
for the record henry lipman the medicaid
director and athena gagnon medicaid
finance director
um try to put together some information
that we hope is responsive to what
you're trying to look at um
and uh based on the last presentation
one of the things i'd share with you is
that you know the original statutory
five percent is what we expect we'll be
needing to draw in the long term the
additional amounts that are occurring
now is because of the unusual
circumstance that's happened because of
the federal
public health emergency that requires
states because they're getting
additional federal matching percentage
to have continuous enrollment as long as
the public health emergency continues
we should find out next week whether
they plan to continue it further
if they
announce next week that it would end it
would end july 15th
and the disenrollment would start august
1st
there's speculation that they may extend
it again partly because of
what they're seeing um uh
epidemiologically but i just want to
give you some sense of that the
the major place where we saw an increase
in enrollment is unfortunately in the
granite advantage program in one sense
maybe it's a good thing compared to
other states that
the
level of poverty comparing where new
hampshire started for example
one in four people in vermont
at the start of the public health
emergency
were in medicaid in new hampshire that
was like one in seven
in maine it was one and one in every 5.5
people so we started with a higher
level of people outside of medicaid and
that the people that
came on particularly at the beginning
was associated with the sudden increase
in unemployment if you remember at the
very early stages we had unemployment
rates up at 17 or more
but you can see across the state on the
second uh
page we showed the increase since march
20th march excuse me the
third week in a march uh of 2020 that
you know the increase in
in
enrollment in the granite advantage
program has been you know pretty uh
comparable across the whole state um
if you look at the the north country a
little bit less because of the
demographics of that area also because
more people
were on medicaid in the north country as
so we today
off you go to the third page
that 71.9 increase in enrollment since
on march 16th of 2020
represents about almost 37 000
individuals
today um
we understand we're protecting
because of the requirement federally
almost 40 000 people
today that
may or may not continue to be eligible
once that public health emergency is
over we're expecting
assuming a public health emergency ends
july 15th that we could get back to a
more normal enrollment by
april of 23 is kind of what we project
if it gets pushed out further that's
obviously going to push that time frame
out
yes
i'm not really
quick hearing oral presentation or
figures but
it sounded like you said that maine and
vermont
had
less
poverty than new hampshire no the
opposite the opposite that they had as a
percentage of the population
they were like 25
in vermont more than 25 percent of the
population is on medicaid whereas in new
hampshire it's under 14
at the start of
this so
you know if you look at also the federal
matching percentage that
maine gets is like over 62 percent and
vermont's over 56 percent new hampshire
is at the
the federal minimum which is 50 percent
similar to massachusetts
stronger
employment
socioeconomic
status if you will good well i'm glad i
asked the question thank you you're
welcome thank you for asking so
we started at 14 where where are we now
so i think probably today we're close to
um
one in
close to six um
in terms of the total population um
and you know for granted advantage it's
been a significant increase i think
we're about
less than 20 percent when you consider
all populations in terms of the the
and
as i said i think
you know as
employment has rebounded and as um
the economy's picked up and i think that
we'll see a significant drop in this
population you know as soon as we're
able to start to unwind
representative murphy thank you aside
from just increased employment and wages
going up
what's the other criteria or metrics
that are going to be
effectively changed say july of 22 if
the emergency is lifted
so the eligibility uh for this program
is
up to a 138 percent of poverty so if
someone is above that now because
they've gotten wage increases or what
have you
they'll likely not be able to continue
on this program they may qualify
to become um on the exchange the for the
federal exchange there are also some
people that because of the continuous
enrollment who were older to begin with
since we couldn't drop them from
enrollment may qualify for medicare at
this point because they may have come on
the program in their late 60s as an
so
just from a historical standpoint when
in 2018 it was senate bill 313 that
implemented the grant advantage program
that original um
source of five percent of the gross
liquor profits uh
uh the formula for that is actually on
the last page we have a little
calculation for you
um by the way we agree with the liquid
commission's money on the amount of
money that's to be
transferred
but then in 2019
the legislature passed
the provision since they capped the
other sources of non-federal share that
in to the extent there was a need for
additional money we could go back to
draw additional money from liquor fund
as i mentioned i think absent the public
health emergency we wouldn't be looking
for that second draw if you will
and then on page five is taken from the
statute the different sources of
of um
of revenue that comes into the program
and then lastly
yeah so what page are we on right now so
i was covering um did a little they're
in the in the yellow is there's a little
teeny number in the upper corner page
four was talking about the
the original funding source which is the
five percent of
of um
gross profits from the
liquor
and then
the
sources of other revenue that
finance granted advantage is what you
see on page
five
and then i was jumping to the last page
excuse me um
which is sort of a history of what we've
drawn going back to
the beginning here from from the program
and underneath the chart is the
additional
part of statute that was added in 2019
that identified if there was a shortfall
beyond the other sources of
funding that we could go back to the
liquor commission for
additional funding which is why if you
look at
line six of
what the liquor
commission passed out
on their second page you'll see that uh
the 8.2 and the 8.7
million those were the additional quests
we needed to to make because the
the population increased by you know
so
we had the insurance department in here
this morning
and looks like they transfer some money
in as well yes uh can you touch on that
yes the the
again back to uh the financing of the
grant advantage program one of the
yep
thank you
quicker than me
the
there's a two percent tax on the
insurance policies because the
managed care under medicaid is delivered
by uh um commercial insurance plans and
so that's subject to the two percent tax
and at the time
the thinking was let's use that
meaning the legislature that let's use
that two percent funding towards funding
this program as well
and so that's that source of money
the the third source
is
the new hampshire health plan which some
people may remember as the high risk
pool
they um
make a contribution as well
that's fixed by statute to be not more
than
um
the same amount that both the liquor
money contributes
the original five percent not the
additional the original five percent
liquor plus the premium tax so
that's the second the third source
and it's only when those three sources
are not
sufficient that we would go back to
liquor
and again we hope that
through the reduction in enrollment we
won't be going back in
and at least state fiscal year 24.
groups around me
if i could just add to that a
is the liquor fund
on it's what we permanently gave to
liquor fund
uh 10 years or more ago
and
it's been diverted to this
as well
because it says the alcohol abuse
prevention treatment right when they
when they
diverted it they left language that
would have expired
that fund completely and uh last term i
got a bill through that
that fixed that problem so that people
knew that it belonged to the alcohol
fund right so that was
being they found other money elsewhere i
don't think i think the senate is much
too creative
they found money elsewhere to give to
so
there's no money from this program is is
fun there's no general fund money that
comes in here correct there's a
prohibition against general fund money
okay funding the non-federal share
which is probably why they were doing
but there's this federal money though
yes it's 90 percent federal so this is
the way we come up with our 10 yeah this
is our 10 sure okay
well that was one i was going to ask you
so with the medicaid advantage we're now
at the fully
10 that were required now at this point
in time right correct and that's where
it's
expected to stay as long as like
statutes in place which i think is no
expectation at least federally and what
percentage of that 10 million that is
listed is the percent is that all of it
or is there other monies that come in
from the state that
from other sources that make up the ten
percent that we're responsible for so
that's the
the original liquor profit money that we
just talked about it's the premium tax
on the medicaid policies themselves
and it's the
new hampshire health plan that has an
assessment on policies
for high risk
that covers the the balance of whatever
those other previous two uh produce
what is the cumulative number for the
the dollars from new hampshire to cover
the ten percent
so um right now it's about uh
so the ten 10 is equal to about 60
million based on the the
60 based on the group that we're
covering now but it's typically been
closer to 38 to 40 million prior to the
group
thank you but again you're from this
point going forward
as you were thinking you were saying is
that this summer should be coming down
um
but what happens after the state of
emergencies left
so that states can begin um
applying redeterminations on
anyone who hasn't had one um and so
whether they're eligible or not right so
we can redo eligibility right now we
can't
once you're in you're in until the
public health emergency is over right so
right they could have gotten a
a better job or something that would
push them over the threshold and
but you couldn't question that
that's what you're saying
or retired whatever
yeah our purpose for having you here was
because we were going through all of the
all of the revenue sources where money's
going off to special things before it
doesn't hit the general fund or the
education trust fund
and there's a whole series of those and
and this is
you know this program requires those
monies coming out of different different
things before we say it
okay
uh representative hackman phillips thank
you mr chair
thank you both for being here today so
i'm acknowledging
and processing the information just
provided us that you know the program
itself has
exponentially expanded in the in the
past couple of years due to the pandemic
um so if the number of granite staters
receiving this has expanded have
i'm just wondering about the state's
kind of footprint
for administering this expanded program
and service
has has the department itself been able
to keep pace with that expansion
so in terms of the head count and the
medicaid program i think between
in my particular section of it we've
been running at a 45 vacancy rate and
continue to run something pretty close
to that so we have really made no
additional staffing changes um to do
this uh and finance i think is somewhat
comparably 25 percent 25 vacancy rates
so you know having more people has
doesn't there isn't like a a direct
stepwise
increase in our work by having um
more individuals it does have some
impact but it's not
um
it's it doesn't work translate directly
that way this is sort of a base amount
of work that has to be done in
interaction with the federal government
on it that
doesn't really change too much based on
saying none all right thank you very
much you're welcome i know there's a lot
to digest we're happy to come back
anytime if you no no think of any other
questions
yes there's
i think another
piece of these transfers that
we forgot to ask the insurance
department about that maybe chris knows
something about we had one year where
workers comp i think it was was really
expensive and it came straight out of
the insurance premium tax
at the last minute and
yeah
yeah i can't remember how long ago it
was at this point but
but the premium tax went down around 50
million i think it was because there had
been some major
i think it was workers comp
on
which
which by law could come out of
so uh i'm not prepared today to talk
about interim studies but um
i just want to take the temperature of
the
who's here
do we want to attempt to do some
in june they usually don't want to see
us around in uh
july
so
we could try to tackle a few i get the
list to everybody
and then um
you know the inum studies we could do
with subcommittees i think we usually do
it that way
um i can i can get the list out to
everybody and they can kind of indicate
which of these they want to be involved
with
obviously they're open to all of us if
you want to want to attend you can
attend
we'll try to balance it republican
democrat again the outcome of interim
study is
is this bill worthy of
being
re-filed next term
[Laughter]
yeah so we'll handle it that way
um
i think we have a bunch of them
not overwhelming number i think it's
about six yeah yeah
yeah yeah i don't think it was more than
ten but
so
that's something we can do and then we
can wrap that up in the uh
september october
time frame
most of these aren't going to
take more than a meeting or two so
um
just something that just again keep on
looking at your your emails and stuff
uh up looks that way i don't i don't
think we're not gonna do revenue
estimates
um
i
you know we'll
you know i know norm norma's talking
about trying to get together
as a group
we could discuss that now um
um
i don't think the issue is i don't think
not at least the next month anyway yeah
yeah i was kind of thinking maybe we
should try to do something in the fall
we were still
yeah we would like to have norm there
yeah
so
we could do it sometime in september
maybe mid to
yeah that storm yeah
yeah
so
so yeah
we usually enjoy those little social
get-together informal
lunch somewhere
and we we always invite uh karen and jen
to come
yes i know
you know
they're still in the world they're still
doing the work in the background now
jen floor our researcher and
oh i got it
so
yeah and actually i mean karen picked up
extra it used to be that they have
two committees
each one of them and now they have like
three or four
no
they they had
ours had five almost euros
really yeah wow
and then she uh not that the time before
that
and then she quit and joined the lbao
and now she's retired
no
but
and jennifer has been great and i've had
i've been able to work with some of the
other researchers up there uh because
i'm on different commissions and stuff
and they do they're all great
right
yeah they make good picks
one of them i figured her name now one
of the researchers up there is um
had her masters in um polish po
polish language
and her thesis was on solidarity
she told me she's definitely going to be
in the gallery
to hear
like fuenza
that's gonna be great seeing him i mean
it's like
he's like to me he's like living history
he's gonna be
the history books could be walking right
yep
before everybody gears up too far
we could probably we could try to pick a
day that we
you know we'll probably pick some place
around here somewhere because
everybody's used to coming to accenture
we've had some good locations over the
years
right it was henniker
we all like that place and i forget the
no no i'm losing plaistow
he's in plaistow yeah
i can't remember that was the one
i think raped
roads probably don't go that way
yeah yeah
but
you know
i think somewhere around here and we
could maybe do it so that we could have
some of these uh
interim study committees meet in the
morning and then
and then
and then so we're in the general area we
did it uh
coming ban one year that was fine
yeah they
yeah
i don't know if this common man has
little rooms last time we were kind of
in the big room with everybody better we
got it we'd like to have like a uh you
know a little
conference room
chris but he's probably not allowed to
come
i don't know i'll ask him because he's
he's he's he's actually very key too he
really is
sorry chris
we would have yet today man
so
all right let's do this i um
i think i need to talk to you and
generian and spillsbury about
about the kino one
and then i need to republicans just hold
for one second about so
i've i've actually suggested to
sometime monday morning
to uh
kind of trying to get ahead of it on the
kino one with gaida's
assistant
can you make monday morning sometime
just keep you keep an eye on your emails
monday morning
well i'm thinking at nine o'clock so we
at what time
yeah i'll make it nine o'clock
it's not i'll come up with another day
we have to be all done by by thursday so
so right
no no i know
we have to go through it we have to go
through the motions here so
all right
okay you have to wait to set it show up
uh yeah whatever room they give us
we'll let you know
so
thanks chris we really appreciate it
tomorrow we still have stuff
cancelled tomorrow yes we're canceling
it we don't have anything we have no we
had two days scheduled in the calendar
now i asked i asked jennifer
i i know i asked jennifer to cancel it
cheap
no no no we
yeah i got the note out to everybody
well i sit on the floor and then
but
no jennifer was going to inform whoever
gets informed to post that the meeting's
not going to happen
not that we draw a big crowd here so
[Laughter]
oh by the way those three girls that
were sitting in the back
i ran into them over and they did girl
scouts
and they must be getting a government
merit badge or something i don't know or
whatever the
girl scout equivalent is yeah
so anyway oh thanks everybody hey by the
way chris thanks for your work
yeah
the insurance department and they
weren't talking to each other and
insurance all of a sudden found out
about this hey our revenues are a lot
lower
okay
um
what's the number yeah oh it's
it's the keynote thing
so
on um 12.1
this could be the quickest meeting in
18th century because once they figure
out the ad 333
i mean i i i worked hard to try to get
i worked hard to say to you know we
were willing to concur
but
then then
it turns up lang brought it up to the
full group and i was i walked in there
were talking about it
then the speaker's head was blowing up
so he said let's just talk about it
offline
later on so i that's why i was a little
late because i i stood around and waited
and the meeting was winding down and
then humburger and mcguire
the speaker and i and i was there
talked us through
and and they were talking about what we
were talking about here
that technically
what you were saying represented on me
that
actually the second part was really the
house position
yeah
so
um
so what we're going to do is we're going
to
non
non-concur ask for committee to buy some
time
so i want this one to be maybe tuesday
or wednesday
to
um
give us some time and and we'll get the
word
and it'll be if and i'll what i'll try
to do i just need so i need four names
i know
um
but you have to leave though and you
have to leave
we're either going to agree or not agree
be honest with you on the keynote bill
because we're just going to walk off the
tip away from the table and it's going
to die
so that'll probably take a half hour
actually
that's what we'll do i can actually the
center will appreciate that too
i don't think you want you want to shout
at this too sure